This is Jocko podcast number
74 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening
now.
I always dug music and I'm pretty sure
it started when my dad would play a Hank
Williams sr on the eight track in his,
I think it was a 1971 barracuda
and he'd play that trip,
that tape just over and over again.
And I still know those songs by
heart. And then, you know, like I,
that was when I was a little kid and
then I got a little bit older and like a
lot of kids, all of a sudden I was
listening to the Beatles. Elvis
thought they were great.
I still think that song,
while my guitar gently
weeps is a good song,
but that wore out kind of quickly and
it was something wasn't there in that
music.
Something just wasn't quite there.
The music didn't sound how I felt.
And then in 1980
ACDC back in black came out
and it was popular. Right?
It was popular.
And so it went into my ears at
some point and I said, Dang,
all right, better closer. Sure. Warmer.
We're getting there and then I washed
around in the hard rock for a while,
Hendrix
led Zeppelin and I can't help throwing
it on a little Jack Black when I say
that. If you watch that
tribute that he did to them
and that you know,
some of the kids that I hung
around with and New England,
they rode that train down to hippiedom.
You know we're talking Crosby,
stills and Nash and Janice Joplin
and the grateful dead and all that.
I couldn't relate, wasn't
there. It didn't get there.
Didn't seem to reflect the world
that I was beginning to see myself.
I got on the other train.
Right,
and we're talking about van Halen.
Yes.
This is the 1980s you know if you were a
kid in America age 13 we got issued the
album 1984 by van Halen.
That was just a given.
You are going to get that
God is your diver down. Boom.
You can need to listen to this.
This is rock and roll people.
This is Eddie van Halen. Listen to that
Guitar Solo eruption listened again.
Do it again. Iron Maiden, right?
Actual Song called trooper, you know, you
got to listen to that when you're a kid.
And so now I'm heading
in the right direction.
I'm feeling it is starting to reflect
what the things are like in my head.
And then there was that day
where I got
an album called black sabbath
by a band called black sabbath.
And the first song is
also called black Sabbath.
And I put that on and boom,
I had found something that sounded
like I was thinking.
And from there I was
definitely on the right train.
Then it was Motorhead and
soon after the Ramones boom.
And then that leads to the sex pistols
cause you're just going harder.
That's what you do.
That's what I was doing.
Like what's a little bit harder than that?
What's a little bit harder than that?
Sex pistols, bodies, no feelings.
They're singing songs, no feelings.
Okay, I hear what you're saying. Louder,
more anger.
And then finally we get to black flag
my war side to still one of my
all time favorites. Minor threat.
Get Ahold of a little band. Another
little band from DC called the bad brains.
Some Detroit hardcore negative approach.
And then so I was, you know, I was
Kinda in the game, right? I was there.
And so 87 rolls around and one of my
friends who is actually more of a metal
head at this time,
he gives me a cassette tape cause this
was dark and the dairy when you were just
going to have to listen to cassette tapes
and they were usually dubbed 47 times
from somebody else.
But the eye,
this was the real tape and
this was the real deal.
This was an actual original with
the full cover on it and everything.
And the cover of this tape was just
a giant mushroom cloud of death and
destruction and above the mushroom cloud
in large old English script blazed.
And across the top it said Cro mags.
Okay.
And then underneath the mushroom cloud
in a little bit smaller script and old
English, it said the age of coral. Okay.
So I put it in my tape deck
and I press play.
And the first track
it hit me like a training
and it's the first track was
called the we got to know.
And let me just tell you the lyrics.
Sure. Struggling in the streets.
Just trying to survive, searching
for the truth, just to keep us alive.
Got To break these cha shackles,
got to break these chains.
The only way we'll do it
as if we use our brains,
there's gotta be some meaning
to the purpose of life.
I know there must be more
than the struggle and strife
looking for the answers
and I need a clue, but my mind
is so disturbed now what do I do
now? I can tell you I was not
struggling in the streets,
but like most teenage kids,
I did feel some shackles,
right?
You feel the shackles of things and I
was looking for answers and I needed to
clue and so I was like, hmm, yeah,
we're on to something. The next
title track had me a little worried.
I'm a little concerned cause you know,
like I said,
there was a lot of kids were taking the
hippie route and so I was not into that.
The next song title had
me a little concerned.
It was the song was called world peace
as I was kind of Oh red flag and then I
listen to the lyrics,
lyrics, all you hippies,
better state start to face reality.
Are You all your far
fetched dreams of anarchy?
Better start to see things the way they
are because the way things are going,
they won't be going far. World piece
can't be done. It just can't exist.
World piece can't be done
and arche is a mess. Okay.
And the rest of the album kept
up that assault on my brain,
on my attitude.
And that was it.
I had found something called
hardcore music and it,
I never really left it.
And I listened to Cro mags and a ton
of other hardcore bands from that time
until now.
And that's pretty much essentially
the soundtrack of much of my life.
And it had a pretty big influence on me.
And it was an attitude
that I kept throughout my life
and it was my own interpretation.
I can tell you that right now.
It was my own kind of, you know,
you listen to the lyrics and you kind
of apply what it means in your world.
That's what I did,
which to me was pretty simple because
to me hardcore meant hardcore.
That's weird. That's pretty simple.
Hardcore in everything. You do.
Work hard to be aggressive, don't back
down, fight for what you believe in,
hold the line.
And that's kind of what I did in my life.
And I dunno,
like a year ago or something,
somebody asked me something about,
you know, on, on the interwebs,
someone said, oh Yo, what, what, what band
should I listen to? You know, I said, oh,
Bob, Blah Blah Cro mags, you
know, check them out, whatever.
And you might want to do that.
And eventually, you know,
it's the, the Internet is an incredible
thing. And eventually I, I, uh,
the founding member of the chromatics
guy by the name of Harley Flanagan,
sure. He like reached out and say,
Hey, what's up man? How are you doing?
And I had heard over the years,
you know,
that Harley was [inaudible] guy,
black belt in Jujitsu. And so, you know,
he's just kinda hit me up
and eventually, you know,
we were talking and he said, Hey, I've
got a book coming out and send it to you.
And I said, cool. Yeah. And he said, man,
the books crazy. And I was kind of like,
yeah, you know? Yeah, I know man, because
you know how I was around that. It's cool.
I get it. It's kind of crazy. And he's
like, no, no, no man, it's, it's crazy.
And I said, okay, cool.
So he sent it to me
and then I read the book and
Damn,
I had, I had no idea, actually,
I had a semblance of an idea, you
know, because in the hardcore scene,
people know each other. I mean like, you
know that you know, you after a show,
you talk to everyone and it's
the band members, it's people.
Everyone kind of knows each other.
So I had heard stories, but the book,
when the reality behind the stories was,
was way more intense and crazy
than I could have a, a thought.
It was and it was one point
when I was reading the book,
I'm going to read a
little excerpt right now
and it said this,
this is hardly when I
started working on this book,
I was staying at a hotel in the red
light district in Amsterdam in Amsterdam.
The working title was the longest
suicide note ever written.
I was trying to document the madness
from as far back as I can remember until
the end,
the story of my life as an insane suicidal
joy ride of rock and roll depravity
and demise until the final crash and burn.
It was going to be a book that all the
great fuckups never got to write cause
they died first.
So I began working on it.
I figured the end would've
come sooner than later,
but I was wrong.
And
once I got done reading the book, I
reached out to Harley and I said, hey man,
there's a lot in this book.
That's crazy.
And the fact that you live through it
in the fact that you got through it and
the fact that you got to the position
that you're in now with your life,
I think a lot of people can learn from it.
And it'd be awesome if you come
onto the podcast and Harley said,
let's do it.
So Harley Flanagan,
welcome to the show, man.
It's great to be here.
Thank you for having me
on. Yeah, it's awesome.
And I saw you several times when I was
a kid and we were trying to figure out
names of clubs where I saw you,
but that was pretty cool and
it's pretty cool to be here.
I guess we're talking about,
uh, 30 years later. You know,
cause I was seeing you
when I was in my teens,
14 1315 around there and here we are.
Pretty amazing trip we've had since then.
Yeah.
And usually when I ask
people, Hey, you know,
talk about where you come from
quickly and kind of where you grew up.
And we don't spend a lot of time there
because most people didn't really do
anything significant that had any long
term impact on their lives when they're
like eight, nine, 10 years
old. Right. But for you,
I mean, when you were eight, nine,
10 years old, shit was already crazy.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, she was pretty
much crazy from the start.
Yeah.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna just kind of pull
a little something here out
of the book just to give
a little bit of background. This is from
Harleys book, hardcore life on my own.
I was born at San Francisco
General Hospital on March 8th,
1967 at the start of the summer of love.
My mom's name is rose
Marie Fillioux fill you,
fail you.
And my dad's name was Harley Wayne Walker.
Flan again.
My mom was a hippie.
My Dad was a drifter and somehow their
paths crossed before the hippie days.
My mom was into all the
early rock and roll stuff,
Motown and pretty much all the music
that was happening when she was young.
Her father, Juan failure. Yes.
One Phil Yu wan Fairview came from
the Dr. The Dominican Republic came to
America through Ellis island by himself
when he was in his early teens and one
was the first was one of the first
Americans to join the United States army
served in world war two where
he played in the military band.
That's how he got his citizenship
by serving in the military.
He was one of the funniest
people I ever knew.
You worked all kinds of different jobs,
everything from building a building super
to a long storm and he was a charming
guy with a thick Spanish accent.
So that's the beginnings.
Do you speak any Spanish a curse?
A little bit about,
so you've got that
now you continue on.
My mom was a go go dancer
and like so many people,
she was caught up in the whole drug
culture of the 60s when I was a kid.
She was still a stripper.
I remember going to work with her a few
times when I was little. That was weird.
Looking back on it now,
there was even a short period of
time when she was a Dominatrix,
but that was later.
My Dad left home for good or
around the same age as me,
maybe 14 or 15 and started
riding freight trains.
He liked to live from moment to
moment and from everything I've heard.
He had a serious drug and
alcohol issues most of his life.
He was always in and out of prison.
It's
hard to accept that your dad
chose heroin and alcohol over you.
It really does kind of hurt even now.
I guess that might be one of the
reasons why it turned out the way I did.
My mom and me did a lot of hitchhiking
and stayed with a lot of different people.
A lot of crazy shit happen on those trips.
At one point,
a friend of hers was going to Europe
and asked, do you want to come?
And my mom was like,
I'm getting the fuck out of here.
She did and I went with
her. I was probably around
three or four that was that.
I never saw my father again.
I stayed in Europe pretty much until
I was about 10 but I come back to the
states every year or so.
We settled down in Denmark,
Denmark and Danish culture
are very wholesome.
It's a great place to grow up,
but of course there's an underside
to in the 60s and in my case,
the late sixties and seventies it was
cool in certain aspects and wasn't so
cool.
And others,
you had all these people fucked
up on drugs and all the free love.
Everybody's fucking everybody.
And it's not really the best
environment for a kid to grow up in.
And as cool as some of the things,
and a lot of the people were,
a lot of them were,
at least some of them
were just fucking lost.
And Yeah, all the kids were
wild. What do you expect? I mean,
we were just in an imitating the grownups,
so as a result,
I was getting laid and doing
all kinds of other crazy shit.
Before I'd even reached puberty,
you basically had a bottle,
a little kids just going off.
You got all these hippie kids
with their hippie parents,
seeing all kinds of craziness.
Adults running around naked
people doing drugs being insane.
That shit rubs off on kids.
Damn.
Yeah. Did you completely think
that was normal at the time?
Was that just the way the world was?
Well, that's the way my world was. Um,
I didn't realize really that we were so
a different from the rest of society,
uh,
until
my parents tried to put me
into a regular school. And, uh,
of course I started getting fucked with
a lot by the kids because I had long
hair and you know, I didn't,
I didn't really fit in and uh,
my parents looked like freaks and now is
when it really hit me. And it was also,
yeah, I went from being at that hippy
school to being in a very strict school in
Denmark, which was like real
old school and very rigid.
So it was total culture shock.
She was like, what the fuck,
you know?
And um,
so I started cutting school a lot and
going back to the free school to visit all
my friends there and just hang out.
And that free school, that's,
that's where you started is that,
that's where he started playing
for as much, you know, I mean,
I was always into music,
but that was really
the first place that facilitated
it. You know, like they,
that was one of the cool things
about that school was um, they really
pushed the arts,
whatever the kid's interests where they
would give you the ability to pursue
that. Unfortunately,
they were also very lax.
So if like you didn't have the
interest in pursuing math or whatever,
they'd be like, oh well, you know, he's
just not interested in it. You know,
he wants to be a musician
and it's like, you know, as,
as we all know as parents is
like, no, fuck that. You need to,
you need to know how to do your math.
You need to know your shit.
You need to know how to use your brain.
You know, it's not just about, you know,
gratifying your artistic and creative
interests because that's not going to
always pay your fucking bills. Yeah.
So, no, but it was, it was cool. It was,
it was cool in certain ways.
Like I said, you know, they, uh,
my math teacher,
he was actually from the states,
he was from the Bronx and,
uh,
he was a jazz drummer
and played standup bass.
And he really was a big
inspiration on me musically.
And so, you know, it gave
me some tools, you know,
that came in handy later
in life. Yeah, for sure.
So you were listening to
actually got your first Gig then?
Like, like you were playing little
Santana covers kool and the gang.
Yeah, my school band was cool. Yeah,
no, they were fucking legit. I mean,
we were like, you know, funky stuff, you
know. I mean, we were plans, like I said,
um, my math teacher, he was one
of the band leaders. So, you know,
you've got a guy from the
Bronx who was a jazz dude.
He's going to be teaching all
these little Danish kids musically,
what's really going on. Right. Because
in Denmark at the time, things like,
you know, Abba was what was big, you know,
so, you know what I mean? So it was like,
what the fuck, you know? So, yeah,
my school was cool as far as music and
a counter culture and all that shit.
But then, you know, then well as, as
you maybe have seen in the book really.
Then when my mother of all people
turned me onto the sex pistols,
that's what really, uh, that
changed everything for me, you know?
Thanks mom. That was, that was,
that was an eye opener. Oh yeah,
the sex pistols. Oh yeah. Yeah. It changed
everything for me. And at that time,
like you got one second
here where you said,
I remember coming off stage and you're
playing with the band that I think the
school band at this point,
I remember coming off stage
one night and these girls,
no, yeah. Not, was hanging out
with, they were like, you know,
that lady you came with, which was
her mom, she's in the bathroom.
She's not feeling too good.
I went in the bathroom and my mom
was throwing up all over the place.
That kind of shit was a kind of come
down back to reality that I have to walk
your mom home. Yeah.
It's fucked up. You know,
little things like that, they stay
with you forever. But, um, you know,
to, to her, uh, she did,
she did sober up eventually and you know,
she's,
she sobered up for about in the
eighties to the day she died.
She was clean and uh,
you know,
Eh, you know, people fall victim to drugs,
to alcohol and sometimes it's hard
to pull yourself out, you know.
But eventually she did, you
know, unfortunately I had to
witness a lot of real, um,
ridiculous shit.
But um,
yeah.
You know, I don't think there's such
a thing as a perfect parent, you know?
Yeah, no, no doubt about that.
And your mom, she did, like you said,
she gets you the sex pistols out and
that they need, like you said in here,
you said, well that was that. Yeah. Yeah.
It's almost concerts. What I was saying,
here we go, go into your book here.
Until that point, I hung around
with all these little hippie kids.
I had long ass hair,
so we were really already little freaks.
We'd walk around the streets, people
would give us looks and trip out on us.
Our parents and teachers had long
hair and beards and shit like that.
But then punk rock came about and
this was more appropriate for me.
It wasn't all peace and love,
it was just more me.
The music was raw and the imagery
and the craziness appealed to me.
It was energetic and a big factor for
me was you didn't have to aspire to be
Jimi Hendrix.
She didn't have to be Carlos Santana.
So you listen to that music and you'd
say, you know what? I can just play it.
I can do this. You can play that, do this.
I can have fun and do this
shit like this is, you know,
you don't need to rack your brain
to figure out how to do this.
You could just do it.
You know your power cords on man,
you just need some Saturday,
man. That's all you need, man.
That's all you fucking mean.
It was funny is I always
tell people this about music.
If you go to a guitar
store anywhere in America,
and you put up a little flyer
in there that says, you know,
I need someone that can play every note
on the following three albums, you know,
and you pick complex, you pick rush
and cart and there too, there'll be,
there'll be, you'll get 10 people that'll
say, yeah, I can play all that stuff,
I'll play it for you right now.
But there's and all those guys,
I mean, a lot of those guys,
unless they have that thing,
unless they have that sincerity that
you're talking about and they have that
little spark of creativity,
it doesn't matter how technical you are,
if you don't have that heart,
you could be technically amazing and have
not one ounce of inspiration and your
fucking body, you know. And uh,
I mean, look, man, you know,
the Ramones were, you
know, some of the worst,
greatest musicians ever. You know,
those guys could barely fucking play.
And they wrote some songs, they wrote
songs that are still anthems, you know,
songs that you will still hear played at,
like major sports arenas or whatever.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah. But you know, music's a fucking
weird thing man. It is. It is.
And uh, you had your first
band called little big boss.
Was that in reference to you? I'm assuming
he must have been years old. You know,
it must've been because the
other two guys in the band,
we were adults and they named the band.
So looking back they probably
named it after me cause I was like,
I guess already tired tyrant to play with.
You know,
you were playing drums at that point.
Yeah.
Hammering all the drums and
then you guys move back to, uh,
back to New York and you're going back
and forth, back and forth to New York.
Yeah, me and my mom, we lived in Europe,
but we would come back every like year
or year and a half or so to see my
grandparents and my aunts and stuff.
And so we always had that connection to
New York. We always came back and I know,
and I,
I was here during all of the pivotal
moments in history in New York. Like,
you know, I remember son of Sam, which
was huge if you were here, you know,
I remember the blackouts, which
were also huge. If you hear,
I remember the garbage strike, which
was also insane because you had like,
you know, 20 foot mountains
of garbage every fucking
where, I mean the city stank.
I mean,
you know,
like I remember all the
madness of New York.
I mean I moved back here for good and 79,
like I guess January or
February of [inaudible] 79.
I mean it was like the weeks it died.
Actually the stimulators we're supposed
to play Max's the one weekend that he
was playing and he died before
the show. But um, yeah, you know,
it was a much different place back then.
You know, you guys know, you know, but um,
you know, a lot of people who've only
been here over the last 20 years,
they have no clue if it
is a different place. And,
and I mean, you know, in,
in the book you got crazy
pictures like you and Andy Warhol.
Yeah. Cause you were just your, your,
it was your aunt Denise that
was running with them? Well, no,
actually he that or is that just a ran?
My mom actually knew him.
She had been in one of his movies when
she was young when she was like 15 or
something.
And um,
that picture was just
taking it at the class show.
Like I used to run into people like
him at different clubs and stuff.
This was the backstage at a clash gig.
The first time they played in New York.
You look like you're about 10. It was a,
I was actually 12 in that picture. Um,
but yeah, I mean I was at all
the clubs all the time, you know,
I mean it was actually,
it was a, you know,
kind of weird, you know,
thinking back on it. Cause like,
I mean, when I, when I, um,
I did a thing with Anthony Bordain awhile
back and he was like, you know, he,
he's like,
I remember standing in front of clubs
like Max's and trying to get in and you
know,
here come this like 12 year old kid and
just like walk through the fucking door.
Like the bouncers were just like, let
him in. Like, you know, he belonged in
there and I'm like, what the fuck?
Why the fuck is this child here? Like,
who let him in and who the fuck is
he and why are they serving him?
Like he's the fucking mayor,
you know? And uh, you know,
thinking back and it's fucking
little strange, you know, I mean,
I was, I was the youngest kid that you
around on the club scene back then.
And then, you know, as
time went on, you know,
my band, the stimulator has really
had a lot to do with it. The,
the crowds at the show has started
getting younger and younger because like,
you know, we started pulling a
very young following, you know,
go figure 12 year old in the band.
And um,
people like the Beastie boys,
they started coming to see it before they
were the Beastie boys. They were like,
they were just fans of ours,
friends of mine,
they were like some of my
best friends growing up. And,
and then a lot of other people who went
on to start a lot of the first wave of
New York hardcore bands were fans of
the stimulators kids who were all like,
you know, in their early teens
when they used to see us play.
And then they went on to start a
lot of the bands that, um, you know,
set off that. Now how long did you
play with the stimulator for? Uh,
I only played with them
from like 79 to like 80,
maybe the beginning of 81.
And then I was done with it because
at that point I had already, you know,
the bad brains had come to
New York and I was already,
and I was all that first hardcore
that came out from, you know,
black flag circle jerks,
minor threat.
And of course bands like discharge
from overseas, from England, you know,
and all that shit was starting to really,
um,
take over my, my, uh, my soul.
And, uh, so I was like, you know what,
I can't play with the fucking steaming
as anymore. That shit is too poppy.
It's too, like, it's happy. It's
just not, it's not where I am.
And at that point, I
had already, you know,
the life I was living on the
streets and the wife that, uh,
the other band members were
living was not really the same.
I was just hitting my teens.
And as we all know, that's when
the problems begin, you know,
that's when you start
getting in trouble. So, yeah.
And the music that I started
writing really reflected the, um,
the feelings that, uh, that I
was having. And, uh, you know,
the cause of the, not just the
environment but just, you know,
everything leading up to that point
had, had created this person. Yeah.
And, uh, and it was a really
violent neighborhood. Yeah.
It was a really violent neighborhood
and I ate a lot of shit for being white.
And, um, which is ironic
because, you know,
I'm according to Minuchin
and I'm Cherokee and Choctaw,
but if you look at me especially, you
know, in all Puerto Rican neighborhood,
I'm a white boy, you know, so I
really ate a lot of shit. I really,
you know,
until I started fighting and
actually started getting more,
I hate to say it,
but it started getting more violent.
That started to earn me a
little bit of respect. And, uh,
I guess the fear and the credibility kind
of went hand in hand. Like when people,
you know, people knew that
they couldn't fuck with me.
I started getting respect and,
um,
I don't really think that's a really
healthy for a young mind to associate
popularity with violence and aggression,
you know?
Yeah. And I mean New York at that
time and like you said, and I,
I used to come down to New York
sometimes when I was younger and it was
completely different, you know,
in the, in the mid eighties.
You were there earlier than that.
But for me in the mid eighties,
when you'd come down here, it
was completely different. I mean,
we're sitting here right now in times
square times square was nuts, man.
There was like, you take two every two
steps, somebody to be offering you drugs,
you know, I used to come here when I
would cut school and just watch people get
pickpocketed watched the hookers turning
tricks and the guy is selling drugs and
the people getting into trouble
and yeah, it was, it was,
it was a fucking free for all. It's
really, and where you were living,
you were living here were strict. Yeah.
Was [inaudible] it was way worse. I mean,
I was talking to ist the other day,
we were talking about,
about, you know, some of our experiences
and uh, just in my area alone,
I mean there was about five or six
gangs within the, you know, 10,
15 block distance,
you know,
everything from the Hitman
on my block who were,
were fucking really out of control and
to the hell's angels on Third Street who
back then were like
legitimately no fucking joke.
I mean,
you know,
I can tell you some fucked up
stories, but you know, you could,
he told me he fucked up stories too.
So where does that go? It goes into uh,
you know, uh, it's just,
it's, it's hard to, uh,
if people go to New York now, it's just
completely different. Yeah, it really is,
man. It's, it's impossible
to really get it. I mean,
the best thing you could do is look at
old movies that Kinda tried to capture
that.
Then you got some pictures in the book
that show the neighborhoods and there you
can tell, you can tell what they look
like, a war zone. I mean, I wouldn't know,
but they look as close to what
they looked like a war zone.
You can take it from me on that one.
Looked like a war zone. I mean, dude,
I was living in a squat. We literally
had no running water, no windows, no.
How old were you when you like
moved out? I, when I was like 14,
you know,
because basically I was getting into so
much trouble in school that they were
about to basically take it
from my mother and put me in
like Spotford and I was like,
fuck this, you know, I had
lost interest in school and,
and all that shit. Yeah.
It's actually funny. I was
something I wanted to tell you.
Um,
when I was 15 actually just right down
there and there was a recruiting center,
army, marines, Navy, the
whole bit. And I was 15. I,
I tried to enlist in the marines,
you know, cause like I, I,
at that point I was already,
I was very,
I guess I had a lot of pent up aggression,
you know, and I was just like, oh,
I just want to fucking, you know,
I probably shouldn't say this.
It probably sounds bad for the military,
but I just wanted to kill this one.
I just wanted to fucking kill.
And I wanted it to be able to,
like, I just was so fucking, ah, you know,
and it didn't help that my mother
was a hippie. So, you know, just,
it's natural for a teenager
to rebel against everything
their parents believe in.
I mean, I had like fucking recruiting,
you know, catalogs and shit under my bed,
whereas most kids probably had,
you know, their playboys and shit.
Like my mom would find my ribs,
every critic shit instead of like
holding up the fucking, you know, Ben,
I was
raised by sudden to me,
no soldier get on their
fucking hippy fucking,
there's, there's a lot of guys
in the military. So I'm like,
fuck this. Through the years, you're
100% right, Chris, through the years,
there's so many guys in the military and
you meet some guy and you're like, hey,
how's it going? And you, you know,
you learn their last name at first,
but then you know, you get to know him a
little bit and you're like, you know, oh,
what's your first name? And they'll
be like, oh, my first name is rainbow.
My first name is, you know,
ocean. And then they go,
yeah, my parents were hippies,
you know, and, and so many kids
rebelled against their hippie parents.
I'm going to [inaudible] I'm going into,
in the seal teams,
that's a very common, so you're 100%
right. It's a good way to rebel.
And I even say this, you know, for me,
you know, hardcore was a rebellion. And,
and going in the military, for me, it was
a rebellion against the norm. You know,
was everyone's going on a, I'm going
to go be a Hippie, smoke dope, uh,
go to college, get a
job. And I was like, no,
I'm going to go be a commando and
just get after it. And Fuck you. So,
you know,
it's fucked up because it's like,
had I followed those instincts,
you know, I mean, you know,
in some ways my life would have been
probably a million times better.
I know how to add a
lot more, you know, uh,
discipline.
I would have had a lot more focused.
I would have had more positive
shit, you know, going on.
I would learn some skills and shit,
but at the same time I wouldn't have
fucking written age aquarelle I wouldn't
have written best wishes. I wouldn't have
influenced people like you would it be,
you know, to go above and beyond what
the fuck I could ever fucking try to do.
You know? So it's like, I feel
like in, in my own way, I,
I managed to do my service to,
you know,
humanity if you will. You know. Although
it was a disservice and a lot of ways,
because I did inspire a lot of people that
do a lot of really fucking wrong shit,
you know? But, but nonetheless, the
inspiration that the, it was real,
it was genuine.
I think that's why a 30 years later
people still give a fuck about that record
and people are still out making
money on that record and you know,
people still cover songs off
that record. You know? And,
and it's funny cause I
was telling you earlier,
he's mean that lineup that played on
that record only lasted for one fucking
record. You know, it's amazing
how short it is a long time,
you know, and it's like, and you know,
it was something special because still
now 30 years later people are still
talking about it and not many people
can say that based on one fucking album.
Yeah. You know, so it's good shit.
Okay,
I got it. I'm just going to go like you
were talking about your neighborhood,
this is just kind of a sample of what
you were living around and in back to the
book, I remember one night lying there
hearing some chick down the street getting
raped. Yeah. And knowing there
wasn't really nothing to do.
It was like a helpless feeling.
You knew that if the cops got called,
it wouldn't matter because they probably
wouldn't show up. And if they did,
it would be too late and they
probably wouldn't find her. Yeah.
One night my mother's then boyfriend got
the tip of his nose almost shot off by
a zip gun. He has a scar to this
day, just because he was white,
looked a little freaky and
was walking down our block.
I remember coming home one
night and my aunt and my mom,
my aunt and an Gustafson,
the stimulators basis got jumped by six
dudes with golf clubs and shit trying to
pull her guitar out of her hands.
You don't really think about a group
of guys jumping two chicks and a kid,
but that shit happened. They didn't
give a fuck. You've got to figure,
a lot of these guys would hang
out and huff glue and shit.
And when you have glue and
you smoke a lot of dust,
you get pretty grim and lean
towards the violence. Yeah.
So there's your, there's your
surroundings, there's your environment.
Yeah. I mean it's, you know,
it's, I'll tell you, man,
it's,
it's a,
okay.
It's almost harder to hear
it being read back to me now,
especially in your voice. But,
uh, but it's like, you know,
it's real and eh,
it brings back a serious
emotional response in me.
You know,
you know, as I was reading that, I was
just thinking of myself because you and I,
you know, in the scene there was
always guys that had dogs, right?
Pit Balls, everyone had pimples.
And as I was reading that, you know,
you and I both know if you take a pit
bull and you bring it up and you beat it
and you've torture it and you heard it,
that dog's going to be
a mean evil bastard.
And if that dog's brother can get brought
up and get fed and get care of and you
know, sleep, it gets treated
good and that, that dogs
and grow up and be nice and,
you know, just thinking, you,
you take a person, a human being,
and you put them in an environment where
that's what they're living with and
that's what they're seeing
and that's what's around them.
They're going to tend
towards that direction. Yeah.
And it's gonna be hard to
break out of that shit.
It is, you know, and, uh, it's, you know,
look around at the world, man. You know,
look at all the, all the fucking
ghetto was everywhere. Look at all the,
you know, all the, you know,
a lot of people don't get outside of this
country, you know, they're live here,
so when people don't realize
how well they have it.
Yeah. Yeah. And even, you
know, I used to laugh,
I was talking to my friend Melly
Mel and uh, we were saying,
I was saying, you know, I
don't even understand what
the fuck's up with all that.
Like West Coast Gang Bang and shit. I
mean, these guys, they, first of all,
they don't even have to deal with winter.
The second fall,
they all got like yards and garages
and fucking barbecues and Shit.
Like we grew up in like apartments with
fucking rats and roaches and you know,
concrete everywhere.
And you know,
what the fuck are you so pissed about
that you need to go and shoot at each
other and kill each other? You that
fucking bored. Like, it's just,
you know,
it is an interesting dynamic here
in New York City the way it is.
That's why I didn't touch it. I mean,
even now that it's like, you know,
soft his fucking baby shit, it's
still intense. Yeah. You know,
I like, I just, I feel
confined when I'm here,
you know, now, now, now,
now that I've grown up,
when I come here and
I live in [inaudible],
I live in California and you're right,
I got a yard and I got a barbecue and my
neighbors have yards and they say good
morning. And it's like, you just,
you have space. Space is a real
thing. And animals, you know,
you can't put an animal, a little
tiny cage, they get pissed off.
And that's what we do with 8 million
people in New York and put him in a little
tiny cages. But it's her getting
pissed off, especially when, you know,
the good majority of them were
broke as shit. Yeah, yeah.
Uh, but this whole time as you're
doing this, at the same time,
you're still, you're listening to music,
you're going to shows all the time.
And like you said, the bad brains
show up. You know, that was a change.
That was a game changer. They were
as groundbreaking as far as for me.
They, they sh they rocked my world
as much as like the sex pistols.
Like they, it was like all of a sudden
it was a new chapter. I, uh, you know,
and the way you wrote, you wrote about
the bad brand. So the bad brands,
for those of you that don't know,
it was a band from DC and they
were pivotal in changing music.
Really a generation of music,
new,
there's all kinds of bands
that referenced them,
like big bands and reference a bad brands.
But here's what you said about
the bad brains. It wasn't
just one thing. Go ahead.
For those who don't know. They were
not only one of the innovators of,
of what we call hardcore punk,
but they were all black and they
were from DC and it, you know,
there was not many
black kids on the scene.
There always was black kids on the seat.
It was always Puerto Rican.
It was always everybody,
you know, we always,
it was always mixed
diversity on the scene,
but they were like the best.
They were the tightest,
they were the best. They were the
fucking, they were this shit man.
And a lot of times when people
first heard their first 45 you know,
just because of the style of the music,
people didn't even know they were black
and they'd go see them and be like,
Oh shit, these guys are black now
that may not seem like a big deal.
Now we're talking about fucking 1980 yeah.
You know,
and yeah, they would just the
fucking, they were the shit man.
And then they got into
Rastafarianism and that, you know,
even further made it even more bizarre.
A bunch of fucking rosters from
DC plan hardcore. You know,
what the fuck is that?
And playing it better than everybody.
Like fucking smoking
motherfucker. Yeah. You know, uh,
you know, I think if you've got to
see the bad brains back in the day,
you're lucky.
I mean,
I remember seeing the bad
brains and just being, you just,
it was just sick.
It'd be like seeing James Brown back
when he had Bootsy Collins on base,
like back in the old,
like when he was like all over the,
I always used to like an HR to Lake James
Brown meets Johnny Rotten. You know?
Here's what you said back to the book.
You hear a lot of crazy stories about HR.
Hr is the,
the singer from the bad brains,
throat in the bad brains.
But as crazy as HR can act at times,
back in the day,
he was inspirational beyond belief.
He in the bad brains had the entire New
York hardcore scene, hardcore scene talk,
talking like fucking Jamaicans.
For the longest time,
everybody was like firebrand and
blood clot. That's hysterical.
It's like the mob.
We're so heavily influenced by them that
the bass player started growing dreads
and wearing a Rasta hat.
A whole contingent of white rosters
started popping up on the hardcore scene.
They took things to another level.
It was impossible not to be
inspired by the bad brains.
The only way to describe HR would be like
James Brown meets Johnny rotten meets
Bob Marley.
He was such a dynamic front man.
Hr could do a standing back flip and
land right at the end of the song,
nail it right at the last beat. It was
like, oh my God, did he just planned that?
I remember one time at a seven,
which was a tiny club within the
first two minutes or so of their show,
he had already knocked the
sheet rock ceiling out and
bent the mic stand in half.
The amount of explosive energy that
would come out of that motherfucker.
You couldn't help but be blown away,
especially since we were all young and
here was this guy that was in shape.
He used to be a javelin thrower back
in high school. He was always athletic,
so he had a bunch of scrawny punk rock
motherfuckers and then this dudes up
there that was an athletic powerhouse
going completely ape shit and he could
sing his ass off and he could hit notes.
Hr came out there with a purpose,
like he was on a mission. Every show
I saw of theirs back then was amazing.
I remember when I saw him up in Boston
one time and he was like going, he,
there was, I guess like fire
pipes or whatever, uh, uh,
sprinkler pipes and he's leaping up and
swinging on those things and jumping off
into crowd. It was nuts.
He was a motherfucker
man. He spent half the show in
the crowd like he was. Yeah.
You know, you can't, you
can't, he just can't even,
you know. Yeah, man, they was something
everybody has that moment though, that,
that period where they really, you know,
well not everybody, but everybody
who's like intense, you know, you know,
you think about your life,
you can think of that one period
where you were just fucking point.
They were around.
I was like 16 and it ended like last week.
All right, well did last
[inaudible] some of us. But
yeah, there was a period when they
were just fucking untouchable and,
and you know, have you seen HR now?
Yeah, I've seen him over the head.
You actually like seen him talk to him?
I,
last time I spoke to him and he came out
to my house was probably around 2011 or
2010 and you know, he's
definitely, you know, he's,
he's got some issues, you know, he, he has
suffered some serious, so he has like, um,
mental issues, you know, I mean, I
don't know what his diagnosis is.
I'm not going to stand here
and pretend to know, but it's,
but you can tell there's a clear
change that that guy from the guy,
now there's something that is definitely
a psychological difference, you know,
and I, you can't just blame it
all on drugs because, you know,
some of us have done plenty of them and
they're fine. So I mean, some, you know,
there's something, you know, and, and
it's really, it's really sad. You know,
their plants, I don't know. I don't know
when or what they're doing and playing.
I mean, and God bless them, you
know, I mean a doctor, no, you know,
he suffered a stroke and a heart attack
and he had to like learn how to use his
hand again and, and everything.
I actually did a benefit, uh,
show us a record that's
available on pledge music.
It's the only place you can get it.
You can't even buy it in stores. And,
and 48% of the music goes to help
him just help him also, you know,
to whatever he needs help with. You know,
cause God knows he's pledged music. Yeah.
What do you search? Pledge,
pledge music. Harley Flanagan.
And the song will come up.
It's the,
one of the songs is called friends
like you and um, but anyway, yeah.
I mean those guys were intense. I mean,
it will never be what it was, you know,
I'm, I'm glad that they're doing
their thing, you know, whatnot.
But I think my memory of them
is from that period. Yeah.
And you probably saw how
many times did you see that
it's unlimited because I have no idea.
I saw them so many times.
I saw them out on the west coast and
you know, excuse me. Yeah,
I saw him in Tiawana.
Oh really? Yeah. But HR wasn't with them,
so it was kinda like, oh cool.
But not that cool. No offense.
Other singers who were really
doing great dudes, great singers.
But it's really hard to follow
in someone's footsteps. I mean,
that was a rough hospital.
That's a rough fall shot.
So meanwhile you did a trip to England.
This is the first time
you saw skinheads before?
Well, I saw, I was getting hired,
I got my head shaved in Ireland.
I had seen skinheads one
time before in London,
but I didn't know what the fuck they
were. I was just like, what the fuck?
Like I could know that
there was something,
they had an interesting look
like they, you know, and,
but the shaved head thing was
what got me and uh, yeah. So I,
I met skinheads in England in the 70s,
but I got my head shaved in Belfast and 19
dean 80. And here's what they
told you, going back to the book,
I always remembered what
the Belfast Skins told me,
teach America about skinheads,
the first few friends of mine to shave
their heads and included Adam Yauch do
that from the Beastie boys and a few
others who weren't really skinheads in the
stereotypical thug way.
They just liked the look and the music.
I mean we were all into the early oily
style music cockney rejects and bands
like that even though it
wasn't really called oil yet.
The two tone thing was happening with
all the Ska bands jumping off like the
specials and selector and madness.
And they were all popular
with the skinheads early on,
but there still wasn't a
skinhead scene in New York.
Just a few friends of mine who were
up on it both in a couple of years.
All that would change. So, obviously the,
uh, the, the typical person when they,
that doesn't follow the music scene
at least at, at a deeper level,
when they think skinhead, the
immediately think of sort of the, uh,
the branch that went off and, and
got the most press, which was the,
the Neo Nazi skinheads.
But the original,
the origins of the skinheads
is actually black dudes,
rude boys,
Ska bands like the specials and madness.
And that's kind of what you saw and,
yeah.
I mean, I actually talk about a
little bit of that in the book.
I give a little bit of the historical
information just to give people a clearer
idea. Um, yeah. But, you know,
the media always let latches onto
whatever is most sensationalistic.
You know, they'd to always
grab the worst aspects of,
of what people are doing
and, um, you know, yeah.
You know, it's, you
got it, you know? Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I'll,
I'll say one more thing.
In the New York scene had always been
more diverse than most hardcore scenes
that always been Spanish
kids, black kids, Asian kids.
A lot of the early New York hardcore
skinheads were Spanish. Yeah.
Mojer from agnostic front, which if you
don't know agnostic front is probably,
they might be considered like the,
Oh,
they're definitely one of the biggest
sort of skin head bands from America.
And they were absolutely the first real
like New York skinhead and you know,
I mean, but uh, yeah. You
know, and he's Cuban logic.
I mean Diego was Puerto Rican as was Jose
from the mob and so were a lot of skin
heads that came around later.
Even back in the Maxxis days,
you had the bad brains,
pure hell,
that influence or one of the first real
New York hardcore bands and they were
all black.
Yeah.
I think where you just pulled up,
I was just talking about the
diversity on the scene in New York.
New York has always been different
from other places as you know, you,
you know, it's one of the things
that's cool about it here. Yeah.
I could say, you could say it's fairly
diverse here in New York City. Fuck,
this has got to be one of them.
I bet you the, I don't know,
you'd have to look at this,
but in New York City,
one of the most diverse places in the,
on the planet,
it's as far as like different languages
spoken. I mean, one thing I noticed that,
you know,
you can eat any type of
food here by a people.
I mean,
we had moved here like three weeks ago.
That's one thing I always loved
about it here. Gangnam style, uh,
dumplings, dumplings,
dumplings in Sushi, served by,
by Gangnam style. Oh, actual guy. Oh.
And meanwhile, you know, at this time
back to the book,
I was drinking a lot huffing glue,
taken pills and lots of LSD and
whatever else. So this whole time,
that's what just prevalent in the scene.
Drugs and New York was a very much,
um, are seeing like to, to get fucked up
in DC. They, where they
invented straight edge,
you know, they were, they were all
about being clean and sober and,
and God blessed them. And uh, you know,
that caught on like wildfire
and other places, you know, uh,
the straight edge movement
spread and whatnot.
And we always went the extreme opposite.
We were like, are we, you know,
they had a song, don't drink, don't
smoke, don't fuck. We used to sing,
you know, we've, we drink, we
smoke, we fuck, fuck you. You know,
and um, yeah, a bunch of fucking idiots.
You know what I mean? W you know,
unfortunately, you know,
at point in my life
and in the hardcore scene,
it was often cool how
fucked up you could be.
You know, and I'm sure it's
that way in a lot of the world,
in a lot of youth culture and in a lot of,
you know,
cruise and gang culture and you know,
I don't mean to theorize,
but I'm going to do it a little bit
of philosophize with you. You know,
like cultures that back in
the day or some cultures,
even today when you want
to prove that you are,
we'll sacrifice yourself
for the tribe a little bit.
Like I'll go hunt that line or I'll go
out and do something that's hard and I'll
take risks for the group
and I'll prove that, that,
that I don't care what happens to me.
I should have been in the police.
I think that, hey, I'm going to prove
that I don't care what's happened to me.
Watch me drink this, watch me, shoot this,
watch me smoke this and whatever. No,
I agree.
I think that that instinct that's still
in us doesn't have a place to be used
properly. And I'll tell you where I got
that philosophy from in the seal teams,
man,
when I came in,
it was like the way that
you kind of proved that you
were tough was drinking and
fighting. Right. Take everything
to a fucking extreme. If
you fucking drank five,
I'll drink 10 yeah,
you fought to motherfuckers off
fight fucking five motherfucking.
That's what it was.
And when the war started,
did not like that stopped
cause that stuff still goes on.
But it definitely in my mind,
in my mind,
I was thinking and we still drank and
we still partied and got after it. But
it was different, man. It was different
to all of a sudden be saying, hey look,
you know what? I need to prove
myself as on the battlefield.
I need to be ready for that. And so I, I,
when I apply that to like all of society,
it seems like a young
kid like you who's 15,
16 years old, how do you prove that you're
tough? How do you prove your manhood?
Oh, you think you can drink 12
shots? I'll drink 20 exactly.
Every thing.
And you know,
you talked about like the straight
edge moving and those guys,
it's interesting if they
took it to another level too,
they stopped fucking name until
they stopped paying then fuck.
And then how did they prove? How did
they then prove that they were tough?
They would go out and fight and beat
up people that were drunk and shit like
that. Well that's what started
happening in some scenes.
And then because like in DC,
those guys were always,
they always tried to be more
PC. They always had a little
bit more consciousness.
But in a lot of other places you
had bands like, you know, you got,
I got in trouble with Ian Mackaye
remember when removing Food
Gazi came on this. So for Ghazi,
one of my buddies from DC, this is,
and the dirty and one of those guys,
one of my buddies, one of my buddies
from DC, they sent me a demo tape.
He's like, Hey, this is, this is eons new
band and you're quite a few thousand. No,
I was like, cool, that's
a great album. Great. Um,
and so we went and saw him in Brooklyn,
me and my boys,
we went down to Brooklyn Museum and we
went berserk because he wasn't feeling
it.
He had like longer curly hair and,
and he's standing there and he put it
like they play their first song and we
just cleared out destroying everything.
He was like,
Hey,
I'm just trying to think of what he say.
So he knows I'm not bullshitting
if he ever hears this.
He said something along the lines of like,
let's leave her,
let's leave our machoism and
our egos at the door, you know,
if you're gonna dance, be
cool or something like that.
And so then I was like,
dude, what do I do now? I get
music, rocks, I want to break stuff.
And I couldn't,
so we just,
I remember when he started going that
route and you know what, God bless him
and you know,
and he has always had it
integrity. And as he,
as he matured, you know,
his his way of thinking.
Yeah. And you know, you gotta respect. I
mean, you held the line with what he did,
his record, he never sold out.
You know what hat's off for sure.
He's fucking legit man.
For sure.
I got the first wreck
for him now at this time.
And you used to break his balls.
Fucking relentless Lee though.
But that's just the way I am. If I,
if I, if I like someone in respect of,
chances are I'm going to really fuck with
them whenever I have the opportunity,
you know, so yeah. Um, so fuck you.
Uh, the, at that time you,
you kind of came up with the name of the,
I actually came up with the Cro mags
name and you started like tagging
everything with the old match
and where you had a kick ass.
I was like,
when we talked about my first,
the hardcore band called
Bronson's children.
First thing we did no music
but we made tee shirts.
They can merchandise. So we,
you know, that's what we did.
And you were doing the same thing,
just different as you could actually
play music. And I was just, uh,
let me see where we're going with this
one. So you started, you started coming,
putting together the band and then things
started getting a little bit crazy.
You beat someone up who's some friend
to someone else and all of a sudden you
heard that you had like
a price on your head.
That was actually before the Cro
mags. Really? Yeah, it was pre chrome.
It's like he made up the name. But you
were nothing. Yeah, that's actually why I
wound up,
I'm heading out to California.
I had to take a little break from my
neighborhood. Yeah, it was pretty intense,
man. This dude, I'm all right. There was
a gang on my blog called the hit man.
And this is back in,
you know,
I remember them from the seventies
through the eighties. I mean,
this is when they still used
to wear colors, you know,
patches on there. In fact,
the Puerto Rican gangs
looked more like bikers,
like Puerto Rican bikers
without bikes back then.
Like they all had like patches and
jeans and like Mc boots and you know,
they'd wear like the f true pats and
total old school, you know, like,
you know, uh, wolf tails and shit,
you know, lack of for college.
This is like ridiculous shit.
If you look on old youtube and then old
photos of New York gangs, it'd be like,
okay, that's what he's talking
about. Yeah. Anyway, yeah,
these guys were fucking,
they were no joke. And one of the
hit men was pig man and he, you know,
they did hits, they weren't called the
hit men, you know, because they, you know,
ro hit songs, you know,
they, you know, they,
besides selling heroin,
they, they did hits and, uh,
okay.
Pig Man.
I've known about him my whole childhood.
He was like a lower east
side myth. Like, you know,
everybody had heard of him but no one
knew. Ya know, cause if you saw him,
that was most likely the
last thing you saw, you know,
but he would wear a pig's mask.
That's why he was called pigs pig man.
And he would pull up in his blue Nova
and fucking blast you with a shotgun.
And it was that simple.
And they actually kicked in a friend of
mine's door and put shots in people's
mouths and guns to their heads.
Whereas Harley in one of the skinhead
apartments looking for me and they came to
my squat and,
uh,
pulled someone into a corner
and put knives to their throats,
which departments Harley in and pig man
was cruising by my friends with the mask
on and didn't see me.
So kept driving I guess.
So it was real. And uh, I'm like,
I was like fucking 15,
you know, I mean, I'm 15.
I got fucking pig man looking for
me. I mean, that's fucking no joke.
This is big man.
Motherfuck Gino Man.
And, uh, I'm like telling the locals,
I'm not black. I'm like, shit man.
And My mother lives on 12th Street.
We know what the fuck.
I don't know what about her.
I don't worry about your mom.
Everybody loves your mom. This,
this, this not personal man.
There's money on evolve,
you know, it's his business,
but you should get outta here,
man. You should hang low.
These are your four to Rican
brother is telling you this. Yeah,
I like the guys on the block.
Just people who knew me from school.
Like people like my friend's uncles and
shit like that, you know, like dude,
you should get the fuck outta here. So
I'm like, you know what, I think I will.
Yeah, just that's cause you beat
somebody up. Yeah, I used to,
I used to get in a lot of fights
and I used to also, you know,
okay,
yeah, I beat someone up. And
it turned out he was, uh,
it was this guy who was a one owner
of one of the after hours clubs.
I'm the lower east side and a lot of
these after hours clubs like you know,
save the robots and the pyramid
and all these other places.
They had like no that like they will the
late night freak clubs where everybody
would go like to a six in the morning and
they would all be doing blow and doing
coke. So I guess that's how they knew
the hitman because they all used to,
all the club freaks used to buy all their
drugs from the Puerto Ricans and the
neighborhoods.
So we were kind of fucking
up their business too because
we were like fucking up
all the, all the new freaks that we're
starting to come to the Lori side,
all the new white people that we
were like, you know, fuck you,
we just made this motherfucking
neighborhoods safe now
you motherfuckers all
thank you. This is gang busters. Like
your just the flood is fucking fuck.
This is our neighborhood now. So
yeah, you know, I was an asshole.
I mean, I, you know, I have to admit
that, you know, looking back, if you know,
if you're ever going to man up, you have
to be able to say yes, I wasn't an or,
you know, but that shit.
Yeah, pig man was no joke.
And I went to California and the
shit died off. I came back, dude,
you went to California and I was reading
that part of the fucking, I said,
what in God's name is going
on to talk about the bats.
Yeah, man, we were living in an
abandoned brewery. Uh, there was,
you know, a couple hundred
kids live in there. Probably.
We were all living in the actual vats
that they used to have the rubber coated
in square rooms, like with a man hole
to get in and out of. And you know,
we were living in the Air Vance and yeah,
it was fucking crazy man.
And everybody was fucked up on drugs.
Everybody was a runway. Everybody
was, you know, it was, um,
what amazes me about the eighties
is the lawlessness, you know,
in New York and in San Francisco,
you know,
like you could really get away with just
about fucking anything and they would
be like,
no police involvement,
no repercussion, you know, I mean,
you'd get into a fight and the shit
could go on for a half a fucking hour,
like from one area to another and back
and forth. You know the guns will fight.
Yeah. Like, I mean, you would
fucking start fighting on avenue a,
you'd end up on first avenue
over on seventh street,
then back over to eighth street and
back down to avenue n and it's like mad
screaming and you know,
stabbings and bottles breaking
and no cops, you know,
that it was like, you know,
I mean shit happens now man.
You fart too fucking loud on the
street here and you got arrested.
I just, so you're 15 years
old, you live in, in a, in a,
in a vat in San Francisco with a
bunch of everyone's running away.
Matt Crystal Meth, fucking shoot and
crystal left, right front and center,
drop in liquid acid in their eyeballs.
How's that even like how do you process
that? And the other weird thing is,
is like you're surviving, you're, you're,
you're getting food to somehow,
right? You're stealing food,
shoplifting and panhandling
and mugging people,
figuring it out, figuring it out.
And that's what everyone in this vat,
these vans are doing. Yeah. Well,
I mean there was only a couple of us
that were out mugging people cause there
was only like me and mark dagger and
a couple of other people who were like
hardasses everybody else was either out
panhandling or turning tricks. You know,
it was like you, you, you, you know,
you were either out Mcginn someone
sucking a dick, begging for change,
you know, and um, did you just think like,
okay, this is what life is like?
Yeah. That's what life was,
you know. I mean, I remember like
eating at soup kitchens, you know,
with like adults and I'm like 15.
And that being weird and like almost
getting into fights with like dudes who
were like ex cons and you know,
like dudes were just got out of
prison who were like to them,
they were still in the prison lunch room,
you know?
And to me I'm just like trying to,
you know, get some food, you know.
And uh, yeah, it was, it was
pretty intense, you know, I mean,
but to be fair, I had a great fucking
time, you know, I mean I had a lot of fun,
you know, the debauchery, the violence,
the drugs. I had a fucking blast.
What?
I recommend any of it and know what I
wish it on my kids or my worst enemies.
No. Did I have a great time? Yes,
I did. How I fucking made it.
I don't know. But you know,
I guess it's, I guess is that
like when people talk about, well,
when people say to me,
Oh,
I think this is the same thing cause I'm
sitting here going, how can that be fun?
But I guess, yeah, no dude.
People asking me about like being not
thinking about the most intense situations
you've been in. It's like the
adrenaline, the fucking, ah, like dude,
the last time I got in like a real
fucking crate. No, not the last time.
The third or fourth.
The last time I got a really
bad violence situation,
like the one it's in the
book when I had like,
I fucked up this dude who was in a gang
and the next thing I know I got like 30
dudes fucking coming after me with pipes,
bads pop up,
Bah smashing out our windows and I'm
running into the crowd of them to save a
friend of mine now. She like, dude,
I was fucking like high for like
a week off of the adrenaline.
And then when I finally came
down and I was like, Whoa,
what the fuck was that
man, I have died, you know,
but like for literally a week after
that shit, I was just like, yeah,
you know, and, and you know, that's like,
but that's the difference between
certain types of people. Like, you know,
I will run into a fucking violence to
save a friend and a lot of fucking people
that I grew up with,
we'll fucking punk out.
I've seen people that I respected fucking
run and leave their friends behind and
there's some real pussy shit,
especially when they're trying
to be all bad ass skinhead.
You ain't nothing but a
bitch, you know? And um,
and hey man,
you know,
and that's one reason why I'm really
fucking proud to be here. You know,
because it's like you guys,
one of the things I respect the most is
someone who will put themselves on the
line for someone else.
Like when you will put your own
life at risk for another person.
There's nothing more admirable than that.
So hats off to you guys and to
all all the military out there,
you know, serving this country and
serving their brothers, their sisters,
their families, and everybody,
you know, hats off, man.
It takes a lot of fucking balls and
I respect and I'm not, you know,
even law enforcement,
you know,
and I'm not a big fan of the
police in many surf. I've,
I've become friends with a lot of
cops since I started doing Jujitsu.
Jujitsu changes a lot of things
for the policy. However, you know,
I still have my reservations,
but I respect again,
anybody who is willing to put their
life on the line for others and for the
greater good and you know,
and there's really nothing higher,
you know?
Yeah.
Well like obviously I got my work with
the police and they're the same way,
man, they're there and
they got, they got the,
one of the hardest jobs in the whole.
Look, I say that with, you know,
a little bit tongue in
cheek, you know, I mean,
it's like I've grown up always being
on the shitty end of the stick when it
comes to the cops. And you
know, still to this day,
even like when I'm trying to get something
achieved and accomplished and I try
to go to them for guidance,
they still look at me like they want to
slap the cuffs on me more than fucking
help me out, you know? So, you
know, but you know, some friends,
but I do understand,
you know,
I what they deal with on a regular basis,
so I get it.
But I also think that a lot of people
are attracted towards lines of work that
give them a, a position where
they can abuse their position.
You know, I think that happens in
human race though. I mean, it's not,
it's like a go do a ride
along with some cops, man.
It is, I couldn't do it
man. The cops is just the,
what they deal with on a day to day basis,
what it does to the brain, you know,
hard ass job.
People don't understand.
I mean it's like there's a certain level
of, uh, you know, once you've seen some,
some shit,
you're always on that edge,
you know, and that fight, that
fight or flight, you know,
and unfortunately they
don't have the choice.
They have no choice but to deal
with at a fight. So, you know, so,
and they got to protect. You
don't have to, of course you see,
oh all we always see the negative thing of
trying to work within certain
guidelines and that makes shitty parts.
End of the time they're there going,
no, Hey sir, please put the bat down.
Put the knife down. That's what
we're doing. Nine days, you know,
socks to hard ass job harder. But
you know, again, I got, I, you know,
I also got to play, uh, I gotta keep
my one foot grounded in the streets.
I still have my you,
you were
uh, yeah. You're conditioned. Yes.
From your childhood that the man you are
is more on the other side here on the
other side, man. Exactly.
On the other side.
And so now that's how
you're conditioned us.
Just like when they, when
they see you. Well, I don't
know if they see, see you now.
Well, you know, things are a little
different now, but you know, hey,
you know,
what the fuck are you going to do?
Well, I'll tell you what I do when
the cops tell you to do something. Oh,
I'd do it. I don't fuck around.
I'm like, look it up. No problem.
No problem. That's how you make friends.
I see my stupid fuck. The feds were like,
Yo, fuck that blah blah blah. It's
like fuck's wrong with you. Oh,
you had to do was say yes sir.
How fucking difficult does that,
you know motherfucker, he
that stupid. Yeah. Um, man,
we haven't even gotten to like
the chromatics yet. Have we? Who?
The chromatics Oh yeah.
Like putting together the first album.
You know what I mean?
Shit.
So
you guys finally get together here.
We go back to the book.
It had been three years since Paris
and use of Paris. The guy was a,
he was the guitar.
It's stars from the Cro mags hooked
up and started writing November 2nd,
1984 and on February 16th,
1985 the cro mags went into high five
studios on 27th street and Park Avenue in
recorded 12 songs.
The age of coral cassette,
which has released on CD called
before the quarrel. Yeah.
That was the original version of the
album before we actually went and recorded
the album,
age of coral.
So that's 84 that that's
going down. Yes. And
that's a good recording.
I have that one too.
I actually like it a lot better than
the album I was telling you before.
I can't tell him I,
I,
someone's granted my head that I
expect little things that aren't there.
And so I, I I liked the first one
better cause I think it's this more raw.
It is more,
we know that it's more explosive.
I think it's more true to what we
actually sounded like when we played live,
you know? Yeah. The other thing,
the other one had, you know,
a lot of productions shit that I
wasn't too happy about. But yeah.
So now this is where now you think
the story has been crazy so far. Echo,
I'll just throw you under the bus
right now. That story has been crazy.
Now it goes,
just takes another kind of what I consider
this an even more bizarre turned and
everything we've talked about so far.
So going back to the book,
I was into Vegetarianism, but it
took me a while to get into Krishna.
At first,
John,
this is the the singer from the Cro mags
or one of the singers that sang the cro
mags.
John and me used to go to the trucks
where they served free food and comp comp
can square park,
which wasn't big hangout back in the day
and everyone used to go there and hang
out. A lot of hardcore kids did.
I mean I was living in a squat,
I was vegetarian, I had no money
and here was free vegetarian food.
They also had a few preaching centers on
the west side that me and John used to
go to to eat,
but still it took a while for to give
a fuck about what they were saying.
I was there for the free food.
I wasn't looking for religion,
I was just hungry and trying to survive.
We would always show up late.
John would tell us when the good time was
just to get the food after the reading
and preaching and everything.
But over time I really started
getting into the philosophy.
In the beginning people didn't
take John and Christina. Seriously.
It was kind of something the
hardcore scene laughed at.
But as my friends and me started getting
into Krishna, it started to change.
So you guys started getting into
Hari Krishna? Yeah. Yes. Yeah.
Which is pretty funny.
Looking back now,
tell me the fundamental philosophies.
I mean obviously Hari
Krishna's are vegetarian. Yeah.
Cause they don't want to like hurt,
you know, animals. The actually,
it's more to it than that.
That's actually not why.
It's because now I'm going to start
fucking talking to all their shit.
Well gimme a little bit of it.
They only eat food that
are offerable to God.
And you can't offer God a rotting
carcass to eat. Okay. You know,
there's, there's nothing that
has to do with like, hey,
we don't want to hurt things. Oh
there's all this karmic stuff. You know,
everybody likes to, you
know, not make more Karma for
themselves, good or bad. See,
that's what I'm saying, like this is why
this is why it gets more bizarre to be,
yeah,
see that's the thing is with the amount
of Karma I had already hated myself.
I was not trying,
but this is where it gets even more fun.
The up and twisted because you got me
and my friends who were like recovering
skinheads for lack of a better
way of putting it. You know,
dudes who he used to go out and get in
like, you know, 20 fights in a night,
you know, put 19 people in
Icu just because you know,
just walking from the east side of the
west side, what you look at it, ah,
you know, fuck you out all night.
Just fucking wild and you know,
and then all that shit with pig man and
this and that and God knows how many
other things, you know, how many
bodies I've found and came across and,
and you know, how many, how much madness
I had it experienced, you know, like
we were talking about, you should know.
It's like sometimes,
you know,
when you're dealing with life and
death on a regular basis, you know,
sometimes you're like, you know,
God, you start calling out the god,
you don't even know what the fuck guide
is and you're just like, God, help me God,
you know, please, you
know, guide me, help.
It's this the call of f of desperation,
you know?
And,
um,
I would have never been into
Christianity and this and that. I just,
it all just sounded like
a bunch of bullshit to me.
And here I was actually hearing some
things that made some sort of sense to my
teenage mind, you know, Karma, Ooh,
you know, all these other things that
like were like resonating me, you know?
And it's like I needed that shit.
You know,
I needed some sort of guidance. And had
I not had something like that, I mean,
it could have been fucking Buddha, it
could have been whatever, you know,
but I needed something that was
greater than you needed to some kind of
guidance. And you're like,
I need guidance. I need
discipline. I needed hope. Hope.
Yeah.
You know?
And when I started going out to
their farm for a little while,
like they were getting,
we were getting up at like five 30 in
the morning and meditating and watching
the sun come up and like it was
like this whole, you know, it
going from like being like hunted by
the gangs in my neighborhood to that.
It was just like,
I can't even really explain
it. It really, it was like,
yeah,
I don't know how to fucking put it
man. It was just like, it was like,
here I am at peace.
I was going to say,
it sounds like people might for
the first time like wow, you know,
so that, but then the more I was
involved in it, the more I seen,
you know that people in
religions in general or are
typically a bunch of fucking
hypocrites,
you know,
you get a lot of people preaching a
lot of shit that they don't all fucking
follow and all rules don't
really fit all people.
You know,
every human is different and not everybody
can follow the same guidelines. And,
and when is,
when did things start becoming just
belief in what the fuck is belief anyway?
It's just what you choose to believe,
you know, unless it's like, this is real,
you know, this is really cutting my face.
That's really blood. This is, you know,
I really have to eat food and breathe.
Air Belief is just that,
you know,
I know I still have,
my spiritual inclinations.
I still believe in some sort of,
I don't like to say the word God
anymore because I don't, I, I,
I don't have that overview
that I know any fucking thing.
I just know,
I know I got a lot of love in my heart
for the people I care about and I know I
want to try to do good things. You
know, I've done enough bad things.
Yeah.
I'd like to try to
prevent some people from
experiencing what I experienced.
And at the same time I
would like to share the,
the great experiences that
I had with people, you know?
Yeah. Well, one of the, one of the
great experiences and one of the things,
the great things that you shared to
people is that that album, that album,
and we'll go to here, going back
to the book, the age of coral,
some would call it one of the most,
if not the most influential
New York hardcore and albums.
It was recorded and mixed in under
100 hours over a 14 day period.
January,
February,
1986 at east side sound by Steve
Remote and Chris Williamson,
our manager and so-called producer.
But it was really Steve.
So 86 comes around and you guys put
together the age of coral. Yeah.
This is the, the one that got released
on a big scale is like the first,
that profile.
Yeah.
It was probably one of the first hardcore
records to ever be put out on a real
major label.
Like something that wasn't like
discord or w slash records or something
underground. Yeah. And, and
now this is, you guys are,
you guys are starting to get a big draw.
I mean huge draws
outside of New York City.
We were starting to tour at this
point and doing, you know, we,
our first big break was touring
with Motorhead and then we got, uh,
you know, we went on to play with many
other metal bands at around that time.
The whole crossover thing. Yeah. For
those of you that don't know crossover,
when he's talking about that,
that's the crossover from hardcore
to metal and kind of combined,
it was really want to have a metal
heads started discovering hard. Right.
When people like Metallica started
wearing Gbh shirts and coming to see the
chrome eggs.
Yeah.
When people like anthrax started
daring to come to CBGBS. Yeah.
You know, and that's really,
but the hardcore bands
started getting more metallic.
Yeah.
Because like metal heads started shaving
their heads and getting into hardcore,
like the kid, like yourself, like kids
who had been listening to Don Halan,
they were little who started
getting into hardcore bands,
started getting more metallic.
We, we definitely to be, I
mean, did agnostic front.
Yeah. Know, they, a lot of people tried
to jump ship, you know, I guess I don't,
I say that kind of jokingly,
but I guess, you know,
it seemed like there was more opportunity
to actually make living bigger on a
bigger audience, you know,
actual record deals, you know,
Pantera, Pantera, fucking
great band cause Pantera,
me and one of my favorite bands
probably, you know, dime bag, uh,
fucking love that dude.
One of the worst tragedies imaginable,
uh, to, uh,
music is motherfucker got shot on stage
for and buy a fucking psychotic fan.
I mean, it's like, you know, like
the fuck man. Yeah. That was awful,
you know. Yeah. It's uh, yeah. I
mean not to, not to talk about,
not to get into, you know, the whole
chrome mag beef and this and that.
But like one thing I will say is,
you know,
it really bothers me that a dime bag
died like that and that they never,
cause I know they would have buried the
hatchet by now and they would have done
an amazing that the union
tour and they would,
if they would have just kicked the shit
out of everybody and they'll never have
that opportunity now
because he was robbed from us.
And to know that my band or
search a bunch of stubborn,
immature fucking old ass holes that we
can never actually embrace each other
purely based on what we did achieve
together and how many fans would be so
happy, you know, because once,
once you're gone, you're gone.
And you know,
it's very rare that four or five people
will have that chemistry for a moment in
life. So, you know, just
based on that alone,
it's pretty fucking sad and
pathetic, you know? Yeah.
And it's weird run that you guys
have, cause you guys, you guys,
you guys were on the verge.
Yeah. I mean, yeah. And,
and when I w you know, when
I remember you guys, um,
touring and I didn't see you on the age
of coral tour cause that was a really
fast talker and you went yeah and I just
didn't have the opportunity to see you
but uh,
I saw you on the best wishes tour,
which was the next album that
came out and you guys were big.
I mean you guys were just to kind
of put it in perspective for people.
Like I think the,
the places where I saw you play,
and this is kind of a national
brand is the house of Blues.
If you've ever been to house of Blues
and I saw you a place that was as big as
the house of Blues, I
used to play there. Okay.
I didn't know you actually played
there but like that kind of venue.
So that's in my mind, you know, that's
legit, that's abandoned that venue,
you know what I mean?
When you're playing places that size,
you can make a living and you,
and if you keep going and stay consistent,
you know,
you can do fairly well for yourself.
But now, now this is the key. So,
you know, age of coral comes out. You guys
are popular, you toured Europe, you know,
you're getting after it, you're
filling up places. Uh, best wishes.
You're filling stuff you're headlining.
Best wishes.
Put your playing with Motorhead to before.
Yeah.
You're supposed to play with black
Sabbath one time. Yeah. By the way,
that would actually be the
ultimate show of all time for me.
Have to fucking agree.
Right?
Cause my favorite bag,
yeah. Black Sabbath didn't show up
because they were having some issues.
But uh, yeah, that, that
was awesome, dude. I made it
on a flyer with black sand
could die down. But here's the crazy
thing is I was reading the book,
I couldn't believe this.
You come home from those tours
and there you have no money. Yeah.
Yeah. And you hear this, this is kind
of like a rock and roll myth, right?
Oh, the guy signs the contract.
If the producer, and I've
watched a bunch of, of, uh,
uh, programs about this and what the,
what the record companies do is they say,
hey look,
we're gonna give you a hundred thousand
dollar advance for your next album.
And then you go,
awesome.
So they give you a hundred grand
and you start spending it, you,
and then they back charge you
for your studio time and the,
and next thing you know,
literally at the end, you haven't even
gone onto it. You owe them $25,000.
You're working to pay it off,
they lend you this money with interest.
And so that's the kind of shit that was
happening with you and you come back off
these tours. You're famous. Cause also
at this time, now that I think about it,
you and the Cro mags,
you guys were like on the cover
of like the metal magazine,
all those stupid metal magazines,
man,
you'd term they'd be like skid row on
one page and us on the next [inaudible]
you're like, I thought, fuck yeah. Is
he on one page? Me On the next, yeah.
So you were there. I mean, yeah,
we were on the cusp right
about to break it, you know,
and you were still broke still.
You would come home from his tours and
still be living on the streets. I would,
I would be coming off those stories and
trying to figure out where I was staying
or I'd be showing up at my grandmother's
house, you know, or I'd be like,
yeah, we got pretty
fucked man. But you know,
you don't know what you don't know.
You know that.
So it's like when you're a kid and uh,
you ain't got no guidance,
nobody looking out for you, you
know, you make a lot of mistakes.
And also back then they had a
bunch of better monopoly there.
Here they're nowadays how to screw
you. You can say, Oh, you know what,
I'll just make my own record and I'll
be able to distribute it through the
Internet and social media, all
this other stuff. You know,
that would have been helpful in
those days as far as you know.
Yeah.
But, um, you know,
I think that the Internet and everything
is also really kind of fucked music up
because it's like people don't have
to have any, uh, lineage or any,
a connection to their roots anymore.
It's like people who don't know anything
could just Google it and cut it and
paste it and call it their own.
And the next thing you know,
they're an artist and it's like,
no, you're not a fucking artist.
You're a fucking cut and paste and
motherfucker who hasn't ever actually
experienced the fucking thing and you
don't even know the history of what you're
imitating. You just know that
you're into it right now.
So you're imitating it right now.
The other crazy thing is
okay,
you know.
Okay.
It was hard to get like these
records when I was a kid. Yeah.
You had to know you couldn't order them.
Yeah.
You had to like get somebody that
was going to go to New York and hey,
if they have this album,
can you pick it up?
Or you go to Bleeker bobs and grab it.
And it was like that he couldn't just,
but nowadays you can if you say, oh the
chromatids are cool cause I heard a song,
you put them into Google,
you get cro mags,
you get every other band
that's been related to them.
You get bounced at Sam like them and
you can just download them all the media
and it's no factor. It's kind
of crazy. That's why for me,
like you know how many record total
record albums I had and I loved music,
I probably had like
okay
80 records,
right?
80 records on my computer
right now on my phone.
I probably got 10,000 records. No
cat on all kinds of songs. Right.
Every band that's ever existed.
I got him on my phone. Then you,
you would shit if you saw
my fucking would shit.
It would fucking be like, like a kid
in a candy store man. You fucking him.
Cause I got everything from back then.
I got it all.
I got like Motorhead test pressings I
got like you're one of those guys gets
test Fresno.
I was watching some video with the Rollins
Rollins and he has my first single,
he bought it from me.
I think he might have one of the most
epic record collections that he likes.
Weird stuff like stuff that like I
wouldn't want it, but he's got, you know,
first pressings test pressing.
He's a freak
and he's got money too, you
know, he's a good dude. Yeah.
You end up trying to
try to sue a little bit.
I think he tried to sue the record
company or something and you end up just
going into legal cost.
What trying to happen was we were trying
desperately to get off of our record
label and get away from our management
because we got to a certain point where
we were just on the verge of
blowing up and profile was,
was still treating us like chumps,
you know, we weren't getting no money,
we weren't getting anything. We were
getting treated like fucking dog shit.
And I'm someone who was working at
Electra was interested in signing us.
So we were like, electro
Metallica, here's our fucking shot.
So we like got to file
profile middlish right.
No profile was actually a hip hop label.
So what they did with us was really kind
of out there out there because they had,
you know,
their big band with century media that
came after no profile was big for run
DMC. That was who there and then
like rob bass, it takes two.
It takes do that was like there,
there was big,
that was their hits run
DMC was their main shit.
Speaking across over run DMC.
Yeah, they brought the metal.
I mean, you know, those
guys were great man.
I saw that first year played
so many times back in the day.
I remember seeing them with the Beastie
boys at the garden and that was a
fucking great show. It was fun, man.
It's like the Beastie
boys brought all like the,
the little white kids and run DMC ball,
the black kids and the black kids with
his walking round Robin all the way
fucking pick off like watching people
just get yoked like an I, I, I'm like,
this shit is hilarious.
It was 40 oh damn.
So you're trying to get off that label
and trying to get on to electric dam
cause electrodes. Yeah. Yeah. That would
have been a good move for us. But um,
profile didn't like us and
they would have rather taken,
you know, they couldn't offer them
enough money to give us our freedom.
They were like fuck
these dudes. Yeah. Yeah.
We had some issues with
some of the people there.
And then you end up so with uh,
with Alpha Omega,
and by the way,
I didn't say this but you
sang on best wishes John.
I sang on like half the
album more or less. You know.
And then me and John both sang on iPhone
Mordoff Omega and I got to read this
from the book cause I got
a kick out of it. Oh boy.
Theory goes back to the book.
You know how you can always tell when
a heavy band is starting to lose their
edge when they start using
a fucking keyboard. Yeah,
we did that.
All right.
To be fair, I was eating a lot of
mushrooms that they recording session.
So like things sounded a little bit
different to me and they were sounding the
keyboards,
how to cool man.
I was eating all kinds of mushrooms and
drinking mushroom tea and I was like,
yeah, that shit sounds cool
to roll with that, you know?
Was he at least I can look back
and laugh at myself? You know?
It's like if you can't fucking laugh
at yourself, man, you're an asshole.
And some other,
I think I might to breeze through it.
But there's another point where you
were talking about how spinal tap ish,
like all this and even that spinal
tap is right. We just started. Yeah.
So Ed, did you want to hear
some really fucking funny?
I mean the me and Doug watched spinal
tap with John one time. Just, just,
just to show you a little bit about his
intellect. All right, we'll watch it.
And about halfway through that movie,
John Turns to me and done goes,
Yo man,
these guys suck.
I've never even heard of them.
Why did they make a movie about them?
Mean dog is look at each other like
this mother thinks this is a real
documentary. Oh my fucking,
anyway, sorry. I had to, hey,
you know what I've seen,
I've seen spinal tap twice live.
Oh, I saw them once. Yeah,
I have a spinal tap lighter.
I brought my wife and you know when they
play big bottoms all play base basis.
Those are fucking brilliant.
No,
but I remember like being in those clubs
where you would find trying to find the
stage. You're walking around and you're
like, all right Cleveland, Cleveland.
You're like fucking outside the club.
Yeah.
Uh,
now
you're still and you're still struggling.
I struggled up until pretty much not that
long ago, two weeks ago. Like I said,
he wrote, you wrote here before
I get into this next chapter,
I'm telling you that I had to lose a lot
of stuff from this error cause I have
kids now and I don't want them to know
exactly how insane things got or to think
I'm a worst piece of shit then
they already will or do. But again,
this is proof that you can plumb it to
the bottom of the worst depths of hell
and still come back and try to become a
better person. There was enough filth,
drugs,
or gs violence and crime during this
period to write a book about nothing
else.
As insane as it was.
And as much fun as I thought
I was having deep down,
I was looking for a way out.
I think that's why I took
everything to such an extreme.
I don't think I cared if I lived.
There were times I
don't think I wanted to.
I'm not proud looking back on it now,
if anything,
I'm sort of surprise.
I survived.
Okay.
Heavy. It's fucked up here. And you
read that Shit Bro. Like it makes me go.
Hmm. But yeah, man, it's true. You know,
you know,
I've seen some of my friends
that
they,
they start to,
I think get the same outlook and
they start doing shit that is,
uh, not, you know, high
survival rate activities.
Yeah. And it's like they're
walking that line of,
you know, well, it's kind
of like you want to die,
but you're not going to take the
pussy route and kill yourself.
So you're just going to do everything
you can to kill yourself without actually
putting a rope around your
neck. So instead of putting
a rope around your neck,
you put a rope around your arm and stick
a fucking needle in it, or you know,
smoke dust until the world
is just a fucking illusion.
You know, I'm going to read this right
here because this is, this is, you know,
here you go back to the book.
At one point I was
broke.
His Shit.
This is after you have three albums signed
by a major record contract toward all
over the world, played with Motorhead
on tour. Here we go back to the book.
At one point I was broke as shit and
I got busted shoplifting food at a
supermarket.
I didn't have any ID,
so the kids I was with ran back to the
house and came back with three of my CD
covers his ID.
I was sitting in this holding area in
the back of the store and the store cops
were looking at me all confused.
They were like, this is your Id.
I was holding up pictures from the age
of coral best wishes and Alpha Omega and
I was like, see, look at the picture
and look at my tattoos. This is me.
They were like, you're kidding, right?
This is all the id you got. That's,
yeah. I didn't even have a fuck. I
had no idea. I had nothing. Dude.
I just realized that I completely breathe.
Breezed over.
Is that I'm saying that you had this
record and you had this record yet.
You're also a sick bassist. I mean like
an unbelievable basis. You know, like,
like she had this incredible
musical talent. You play drums too,
but I mean your bass playing is drama,
but that's well and good.
But your base plan is sick.
So he had all this talent and you had
records and you had fans and you had all
the shit and you're still down in the down
in the dirt, shoplifting, shoplifting,
fucking smoking ice dude. Hey Man.
You know, it could've been worse,
man. I mean, look at fucking
people like Jocko Pistorious.
I mean that mother fucker was like
the most spaces. Yeah, like the,
and Jimmy Hendrix,
you know,
he was the Jimi Hendrix of base and
look at Jimmy and him and it's like,
you know, you can have all that
talent and if you're, you know,
if you're suffering on the inside,
man, you know, me and fucking Jocko,
there's another tragedy. Motherfucker got
beat to death by a balancer. You know,
who didn't know who he was.
This is not this Jocko,
Jocko Pistorius.
He actually got tried to get up on stage
at a Santana show him because he was
friends with Santana and he tried to get
up on the stage and he was so fucking
messy at the time that
nobody could recognize him.
And the bouncers threw him out and he
kept being belligerent and they beat him
to death. You know? So it's like you
can have all the talent in the world,
but you know it's,
it's this,
it's sad because really the people who
are have that gift usually are people who
are really emotionally well that's why
they have that gift because they're so
fucking emotional, you know? I
think you know that definitely.
Then that can really become destructive
if you don't have a positive place.
Like if you're really,
the only times in my life where I haven't
been all fucked up on drugs was when I
had something constructive to do
something that gave me a purpose.
And when you have that creative,
emotional
self destructive thing in you,
because it really can become
self destructive if you
don't have a place to put
it. I mean, shit man,
if you wouldn't have fucking gone into
the military and God knows what the fuck
you would have done with that intensity.
No, the military I've talked about that,
you know, I mean it's like it's
a beautiful thing for me. Yeah.
I mean you probably would have been for
me too. I just wound up. But you know, in,
instead I wound up being a soundtrack
to your yeah. But a lot of,
a lot of fighters,
you know,
a lot of UFC fighters and stuff and a
lot of those guys have a rough time,
you know?
Absolutely.
It's hard to be that type of an intense
person and to go to such extreme
emotional dumps because,
you know,
one second you're just a
tough guy on the street.
The next second you're a tough guy in
front of fucking thousands of people and
there's lights flashing everywhere,
you know? And then, you know,
okay.
And then some people,
it's like your career has done and you're
still that tough guy who still will
fuck shit up, but nobody gives a
fuck. And now if you fuck somebody up,
you're going to fucking jail. You
know? And it's like, you know,
and drugs become an easy way to deal
with fame and the confusion of popularity
and the depression.
It's a heavy thing to go from,
ah,
to the silence of your room and your mind.
There's a buddy of mine plays
in a band called slightly
and they're actually a big band.
And they play in front.
They're from San Diego and one of the
guys in, and he, you know, we were just,
you know, he's got a little
kid, he's a normal guy,
but he plays in a slightly
stupid and he was, you know,
they just got back from tour and you know,
I just said something to mud.
How wasn't he goes, man, that
just never gets old. You know,
getting up in front of 10,000 people that
are singing your songs, man. He said,
it's just like unbelievable
man. I tell you, man,
I haven't been in taught on tour
in a really long time and, and um,
last time I gigged out.
I think the last time I did
a tour was like 2011 or 12.
And then a lot of shit went
south in my life. Go figure.
And I needed time to
pull myself back up and
get my shit back together.
I'm going on tour in about nine days.
I'll be playing in Berlin first.
I'm going to be playing a bunch of shows
in Germany. I'll be playing in Venice,
in Italy and I'll be
playing in Switzerland.
I believe in Belgium and the UK.
I'm going to have about 13,
12 or 13 shows and 13 or 14 days.
I'm really, really looking
forward to this. Um,
I'm not looking forward to driving five,
six hour drive,
so I'm not looking forward
to not sleeping in my bed.
I'm not looking forward to
not waking up next to my wife.
I'm not looking forward to all that shit,
but I'm really fucking looking
forward to doing my thing again.
You know,
I got so involved with Jujitsu
and teaching Jujitsu and stuff,
that music actually started
to take kind of a back seat,
especially when I had my kids and I
really couldn't tour and stuff anymore.
Uh, why? It was a choice I made. I mean,
I could have done whatever
the fuck I wanted,
but I chose to be there for my kids.
Now they're older and
so on. And Life is, uh,
has made this possible to do again.
I can't wait man.
And um, you know, this
okay.
Affecting people the way I, you
know, you do with music, it's a,
you make a connection, you know,
you know, you, you know, look man,
I'm sitting across from you now because
of a fucking album I did 30 fucking
years ago. Was that fucking
tell you, you know, it's good.
MMM.
You're going back to book here.
You're, you're at that point, you know,
you,
this is know the same time period where
you're getting arrested for shoplifting.
Okay,
here we go. I was in a state of depression
and the drugs helped me stay in it.
I was trying to get better as far as
wanting to get off drugs at least half the
time, and I would for a few days
or a week or so here or there,
but I was just too depressed and
one thing would lead to another.
Then back in to the abyss,
the death spiral into emptiness,
nothing and nowhere ness.
Of course I was all into Alice and chains
and nine inch nails and all of that
fucking depressed drug music.
But even as fucked up as I was,
okay
there was this wheat grass juice stand
on mission and I'd still make sure to go
get a shot of wheat grass juice
every day because I figured, hey,
at least wheat grass juice is
equal to eating tons of vegetables.
But I was trying to sort of stay
healthy. Like I was like, okay,
I know I'm not eating regularly
and I'm not eating very well,
so let me at least try
to, you know, and this is,
this is another thing that's
again I think this Georgia state.
So I go to monkeys, Dorothy heroin
and fucking wheat grass juice.
Horrible.
I'd go to music stores and pretend I
was going to buy shit and just play
instruments. I'd hang out as
long as I could and then leave.
I actually got offered gigs
while I was playing in stores.
I got offered gigs for doing
sessions for different producers,
but I'd be all fucked up and miss the
session cause I wouldn't know what day it
was. And then realize a day or two later
I'd boot lose their business card or
whatever.
So you just can't get your shit.
I was pretty fucking,
it was embarrassing.
And that was by the way that was
taking place out on the west coast.
It sounds like. I went to San Francisco
to clean, get clean off drugs.
I was like the worst city.
Fuck I clean.
I haven't you ever heard of Idaho or
where you're new to checkout Idaho or
Montana? Uh, thank you. Move back,
move back to New York and now you start
kind of bringing it back together.
I'd go for these long runs at
night cause I couldn't sleep. Uh,
your girl lived down by the twin towers
and I'd run from there to central park
and back on the way it stopped
by Coney island high on,
on Saint Mark's place to see who
was hanging out for a few minutes.
Say Hi then keep running
uptown to the top of the park.
I'd run a few laps around the reservoir
and then turn around and head back down
on the way back down.
It stopped at Coney island high again
and there would be the same people.
Everyone was pretty
much in the same place,
just slightly more shit faced and had
hang for a few more minutes and then keep
running.
It was kind of good to see that as I
was getting my shit together to see all
these people not really doing anything
but standing around getting fucked up as
they got older and did
nothing with themselves.
It gave me motivation to
keep my shit together.
So
yeah, that's when I started
pulling myself back up.
You know in one of the things that
helped with that, first of
all, you guys got def jam,
you guys got signed to Def
Jam, is that right? We had a,
they gave you an advance or something,
but we got an advance to record something
for them and then the deal wound up
falling apart.
So we wound up
being left with the recordings in our
possession that we were able to then put
out ourselves what, what
album was on revenge. Okay.
Which I thought was actually a
really good album, but, um, you know,
it is what it is. But didn't think
shit, never managed to stay together.
That band just had fucked up Karma
and all around this time you
started your Jiu Jitsu career. Yes.
Yeah. Well that's, you know, I,
I've said it many times, man,
Hanzo really fucking saved my
life and a lot of ways cause uh,
you know, even though I
was doing those, you know,
12 mile runs and shit like that,
I mean,
I've worked my way up to really do one
long ones. I started off doing like three,
four miles.
I got into it,
but I would still have my moments
of just like a depression and um,
just,
and I'd want to get fucked up and stuff.
But I had Jujitsu and,
uh,
I was living in my rehearsal studio.
I didn't even have a fucking shower.
I was like bathing on the roof with
filling up a two gallon buckets.
I'd go up there were like four or
five buckets and just like babe,
I was living in the rehearsal
studio. I wasn't, you know,
life was not great,
but every day I'd go and I'd train and uh,
that gave me a place to,
uh, to find myself again.
You know. When was this, what
year? Uh, it was like January,
February of [inaudible] 96.
Okay. Like when I've came back,
I discovered a MMA from UFC one and
two when I was out on the west coast.
And I'm like, what the fuck
did he just do to him? Like,
I would probably, you know, hit
a thousand people in the face.
I kicked the thousand people in the
head and the head butted and bitten,
whatever.
But I ain't never seen a triangle
choke thought fuck is an arm bar,
you know? And I made up my mind, this is
when I was still on smack. I was like,
I made up my mind. I was like, Yo, if I
ever get the chance to learn that shit,
I'm gonna fuck them, learn that shit.
So when I came back to New York,
I just kept going through like black
belt magazine, Kung Fu magazine.
Like one of these motherfuckers got
to move out here sooner or later.
This is New York.
I mean they can't all stay in California.
They fucking room Gracie's
they're like a very big family.
One of them is going to have to move out
here. So Hanzo get moved. I found an ad,
Enzo Ku cook,
Gracie Kukoc had said Gracie Kuka Yeager's
still with his old partner and yeah
man,
I went down and I met Hanzo and that
changed my life and I was 21 years ago,
you know, and, and a lot of people are,
they think I why they think it, but they
think Jiu Jitsu is going to be, you know,
kind of when you walk in it's going
to be intimidating. And it, you know,
I could tell from the way you wrote
about it hands, I was just like, Hey,
what's up broad,
you know,
he just makes you feel so
welcome and so at home. Yeah.
And um,
okay.
He's, you know, I can
say this and mean it.
You know, I, I really loved
that man. You know, he,
he was there for me through some of the
toughest parts of my life and he didn't
give up on me and he believed in me.
And sometimes really that's all you need
is somebody to believe in you and did
not give up on you. And, um, you know,
when I got arrested in 2012 and I was
all over the papers and the news and
everywhere, you know, they,
a lot of people were shying away
from me. Let's just say that. Um,
for those of you who don't know,
I got jumped by about five or six guys.
Uh,
and I wound up biting a nice chunk out
of one of their faces and slice in a
couple of them and poke and one of them
and the process of the me getting jumped,
I got 40 stitches. I was stabbed. And,
um, you know, a lot of people were like,
you know, I can't believe he did
that, blah, blah, blah. I'm like,
did what got jumped? You
know, I got fucking jump man,
the fucking telling me about slice and
cut and stab it and fucking telling me
shit about shit until you got five or
six motherfuckers trying to take your
fucking life,
you know,
then you can start talking
about how could you do this?
How could you fuck you? You know, you
got five dudes kicking you in your face,
stomping on you.
You had better be willing to stab it,
bite or rip someone's balls off.
You know?
And that's what people
don't fucking understand,
who have never experienced
real violence or real
potential of death. Uh, you know,
when I first got into Jujitsu,
it was all about the fighting.
You know? I was like, yeah,
learn more ways to fuck people
up. Yeah. I now I really, it's,
it has nothing to do with fighting for
me anymore. I mean, I just love the art.
I love the relationships that
I've made through the art.
I love sharing what I've learned.
If anything,
I'm a
okay.
Again, you know, the fight or flight man,
I'm way more likely to run then
fight at this point because I know
how bad things can go.
Yeah.
You know like yeah definitely. I actually,
I might have told this story before,
there was a bad ass marine
and his name was Da.
That's what everyone called him and da in,
in the military DSLR for short,
for direct action. But that was
his initials too. But it just,
so it just worked and he
looked like a superhero.
He's a total stud and he was a gang
banger from Texas and, but you know,
he joined them or even to be like you.
Right. But he joined but he's a black kid.
But he joined the Marine Corps and he was
in force recon. He was a total bad ass.
And I, and I said, hey man, you
got to come and try Jujitsu out.
And so he started training. They
like, after like six months,
he came up to me and I was
like, hey man, you know,
cause I was like still deploying and
he's, I wouldn't see him a lot. Nice.
Almost like a mad how you, how do
you like Jujitsu? He was like, man,
it's kind of fucked up.
What do you mean bro? It's,
it's awesome. He goes, he goes,
no man cause I used to
feel like a real bad ass.
Now everybody has to you I'm
thinking about, I might be a pussy.
So yeah man
it is funny. It's very humbling, very,
very humbling game to play. It really
is. But you know at the same time though,
to me it is, it is that though it
is a game for me. It's like when,
when I think of fighting
or when I think of,
okay
self defense, I, I I I believe in Jujitsu.
I mean I am 100% of believer but
Jujitsu is fun for me. It's not about
violence or self defense or fighting,
you know,
cause he's fighting and violence to me
is about ending something is ending.
Somebody, you know, I mean
cause I know I could die.
It doesn't, I tell people all the
fucking time, I'm like, you know,
you don't got to worry about like uh,
you know a blackbelt kicking your ass.
Cause he's a black belt. He's already
matured past the need to kick your ass.
You got to worry about that
90 pound mother fucker who
will stab you without you
even having a chance to say,
dude, we don't need to have
a problem. Right. You know,
you got to worry about that dude who's
just so don't give a fuck that before you
even have a chance to say buddy,
your shirts wet and you're like,
oh shit. You know? Yeah. And um, right.
We've talked about that on
here. You know, people say like,
oh I was going to get no,
this guy said something to my wife,
what should I have done? I'm like, just
to grab your wife, go home and buy her,
you know, a nice dinner and yeah, I say,
honey, I love you. You don't, I don't,
it's not worth getting stabbed in the
neck and it's not worth having to stab
that junky in the neck either.
And I just know from my own experience
that there's always the potential that I
could go to that extreme.
I don't think for one second because
I'm a Jujitsu black belt that like,
I'm just going to submit this guy and
hold them down until the police get here.
Because you know what that guy may have
through other friends standing in the
shadows behind you or that guy may
fucking start stabbing you when you're
looking to fuck and you're
trying to, you know, submit him
and all of a sudden you're
like, why? Why is that
shirt wet? Well, you know, why
is my pants wet? Oh my God,
that's fucking red. You know? I mean,
that's just life, you know?
That's, that's why, um, you know,
now as good as Jujitsu isn't
as good as you felt doing it,
you go on tour and just before we go on
to where you break up with a girl at the
time, blah, blah, blah,
back to the book without
the feeling of being needed,
I didn't feel I had
much purpose in my life.
I started falling back into fuckup mode.
I was seeing several different
chicks around at that time.
Hey, you wrote the book and it's wrong.
Correct. Done on her. I'm Craig can,
you know,
it wasn't even so much over just a
breakup of a chick. I was actually,
I've been with this chick for a while
and she had a daughter and I had raised
her daughter. Oh. So
it was like, you know,
also not just feeling like betrayed and
everything else that goes along with a
breakup. But as any father
or step father stepmother,
you know, you have a
certain, uh, you know,
you develop love for a kid even
if it's not yours, you know?
And that was really what was a hard on
me more than anything because the mother
was all fucked up on drugs and I had
actually taken the kid from her and I was
raising the kid for her while
she was off just being a fuck up.
And then the grandparents
and me gotten contact.
So I wound up doing, you know what?
You do it again. This is your family,
this is your blood. Thank you. Got To
grow up with your family. So that was,
that's why I was struggling, you know, it
was because it was like, you know, I was,
I never had a father that
gave a fuck about me.
So every time I've been in a child's life,
it has really mattered to
me. He liked to be, uh,
to protect them because no
one protected me, you know?
So, um, so that was why I really
started to lose my way again,
you know, cause I was like, you
know, uh, I don't have a purpose.
There's no one for me to love no one for
me to care about and knowing the field,
uh, my, my love, you know?
So yeah, the drugs started to
fill in the gap again, you know,
but fortunately that didn't last forever.
It's funny, man, some of the fucking,
some of the toughest motherfuckers
actually got the biggest hearts.
And that's what a lot of people
don't realize is, you know,
I'm sure that underneath
this rugged exterior,
you're quite a sensitive motherfucker, you
know? And, um, are you talking about me?
No, I'm talking about the
guy behind you. But, uh,
you know, I mean, seriously,
some of the most eldest motherfuckers
I've known in my life have been some of
the most sensitive people on the inside.
And I think that part of that
illness
has been a shield,
you know,
to protect themselves.
I know it probably was with me
and a lot of ways, you know,
if I wasn't as violent as I was,
my neighborhood would have devoured me,
my environment would have
devoured me if I wasn't as,
Yup.
So to your point,
I agree with you and that's one of the
reasons why I think going back to Jujitsu
or boxing or wrestling or Moy,
Tai,
but win win
you me when we're kids,
young men,
going back to the whole
thing about proving yourself,
how are you going to prove yourself
that you're tough when you're a kid,
you go out and you fight and
you beat people up too stupid.
You do stupid stuff when you do Jujitsu,
you know you're tough and,
and you know when you look at
some guy in the street like, Hey,
that guy might stab me, but
if he doesn't, I'm going to,
I will choke them out and to take me 15
seconds so I don't have to do anything
to prove.
That's why I think it's for me.
And I think it was Tim Ferriss
asked me this question, he was like,
what makes a man or something like
that. And I was like, to your point,
for me, learning how to
fight. So learning, Jujitsu,
getting married and having
kids and going into combat,
those were the three things that I
was like, okay, those three things.
They were evolutionary to me and they
were the three things that happened where
I said,
okay,
I don't have to walk around trying to
prove myself to this guy or that guy.
I know how to fight.
I don't even know need to impress
that girl over there. I got a girl,
you know, and I got and I got mouths
to feed so I can't act like an idiot.
And I know I'm not a coward
in if shit goes down,
I know that I will do the right thing.
I know that 100%.
So those were the things that to
me gave me like security as a man.
And so it's the same thing that
you're saying how, you know,
when we're young and you're out
there just to try and prove and,
and protect and shield your,
your emotions, your sensitivity,
you know? Yeah. That's what you do.
And so a good way to get over
that in my opinion, is you,
instead of having to fake it,
you learn it for real.
I wish I would've had Jujitsu
when I was a young kid.
That would have helped me immensely,
you know? Yeah. Um, well I mean,
just to just,
just
one person not just mentioned
briefly is, um, high end Gracie,
uh, another brother that
I, I truly love. And uh,
you know,
he died in 2007.
It was a very tragic,
and um,
here's a guy who was feared by
99.9% of the people that knew him.
And the 1% of people that
knew him fucking loved them.
And he was, you know, it's
like I'm saying like, you know,
you got these people who are
fucking dangerous motherfuckers.
You don't even want to look at them
wrong or for too long, you know?
But if they fucking love you, man, nobody
better fuck with you. Ever go there.
You got a part in, in the book where
you're talking about he came home,
he fought in Japan, he comes
home, he gives you, you know,
you just had your first kid. It gives you
two grand. Yeah. If for not for nothing,
just for being you. And I didn't want to
take it and he's like, shut the fuck up.
It's for the baby. You know? I mean,
I know motherfuckers my whole life
we didn't do that for me. You know,
you know Dean Dean lister,
who's,
you don't want one of my friends
and training partners and all that,
but he's got some funny stories
about high end and he's like, hi.
It was fucking crazy back. He was
a crazy motherfucker. But, but,
but to be honest though,
I never had any crazy experiences with
them because I feel like when he looked
into my eyes, he knew he didn't
have to prove anything to me. Yeah.
You guys kind of countered it out.
What's that called?
Is canceled. Well, it was like, you know,
I don't have to prove
I'm a bad ass to you.
You don't have to prove you're a bad
ass to me. Let's just go out and chill.
That's good. You know, we'd go out and
like go to stupid movies, like, you know,
go out and just work on
his English, you know,
like, I never, you know,
yeah. We had fun, you know,
but we never like gotten brawls
and got know. But I mean, you know,
he died. Yeah. He got,
uh, he got arrested.
It was a bad situation. You know,
again, it's like, you know, again,
this is somebody who was
very emotional and a sadly,
you know,
like many people started using drugs as a,
as a way to deal with shit, I guess.
I don't want to say to deal with shit,
but maybe just as a little
bit of an escape, you know,
you've got to figure what
kind of fucking, uh, you know,
I mean his favorite song was a boy named
sue by Johnny Cash and he really felt
like he was living that life by being him,
you know,
with the name Gracie and having to be,
you know, always having to step up,
always having to prove himself
and always having to be a bad ass.
And I think that when you're forced to
react and deal with things on that level
all the time,
and especially when you are
actually a nice person at heart or,
or a sensitive person at heart,
when you're forced to always take that
stance as shit to fucking tough one man,
you know, that's a hard road
to travel. And um, you know,
I always have him with me always.
I always have him sitting on one shoulder
and hands, oh, sitting on the other.
And uh, you know, when I look
back on it, yeah. When I have big,
when I am confronted by,
you know, serious shit,
I think about,
you know,
how one would react and how
the other would react. And,
and then I tried to find my
own sense in there. Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it's high.
It's kind of a classic example
of everything that we're
talking of. I mean, yeah.
For all, for all practical purposes.
You shouldn't be here right now.
You up either dead or in jail or whatever.
Yeah.
And he did his shit that was going
down the same path, but he didn't,
didn't make it to make it
happen, you know? And uh,
that's, you know, that's the,
that's the thing,
man.
I feel really fortunate that I had music
because I think that it gave me a tool
to, to, uh, it gave me a paddle
to row my wave through the shit.
Okay.
But it also came with its
own load of shit. You know,
it's funny cause I, you know,
I probably should have encouraged my kids
to learn more about music and be more
musical, but I encouraged them to
be Jujitsu guys because I felt that,
you know, MMA is way safer.
Better. There's less.
It's less off road. Yes.
Bad exits. You can know,
you might get punched in your face it
bunch of times, but at least you want,
you know, at least it won't be life
punching you in your face, you know,
and there's, you know, all
kinds of drama around it.
You described it to get a spinal tap,
you know,
just the rock and roll crap.
Cro mags comes to an end for the most
part and you end up putting out outer
record Harley's war.
Yeah.
And um,
good,
good rock and roll music baby.
And uh,
now and also during that time you,
you had some kits.
Yeah. And you know, you,
you met the mother of your kids and she
wanted to go to school and so you took
off some time to just, yes. I pretty much
put my musical career on hold.
Okay.
You know,
to take care of your kids. Yeah. And uh,
you know, one of the, one
of the paragraphs that you
wrote in here is awesome. Um,
talking about your kids and you say,
and this is something I
completely related to,
I'll tell you the first time I looked
down at the other end of the mats and saw
my boys training. It was one of
the greatest moments in my life.
My youngest son spent his birthday at
the Academy with George Saint Pierre and
all the rest of the fellas.
My eldest son had his birthday there
with all the Gracies in about 30 kids,
a full house and a cake with a
Henzel Gracie Academy logo on it.
My sons have grown up with Hanzo
like an uncle Igor halls, Gregor,
Daniel, Neiman, all the guys
treat my boys like family.
They've known their instructor
Magno Gama since birth.
He came to the hospital to see them
hours after they were born at Hanzo.
They have known since they were days old.
My oldest and I have been on Greyhound
buses in the middle of the night
traveling hours away to represent
RGA and team hands. Oh Gracie.
I've competed with my son's net at
nationally ranked grappling submission and
Jujitsu events.
One of my proudest moments was when we
both competed at the same event by son
took first place in his division and I
took second place in the expert Masters
Division in the 30 to 35 year old
age bracket. Although I was 44 hens.
Oh joked when he first saw my son.
This is the proof that even
though the fruit is rotten,
the seed can still be good.
That's uh, yeah, we, we all know that one.
And you know,
I,
I guess it's when you see your kid doing
anything that you love doing and you
see, get to see your kid do it,
Echo, you got that in your future.
When you see your kid,
I'll wait.
[inaudible] you see your daughter on the
mat right now and uh, that, that's cool.
When you see your kid like training
and I'm to the point right now,
my son's a big kid. He's 14 but
he's, I can roll with it, man.
I can legit that can roll with that taller
than me. Yeah. He's my 14 year olds.
Six foot buck 80. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's awesome when you,
when you get to train and you know,
the other thing I noticed
while I surf and when my son
as good as it feels to surf like as good,
there's a really good feeling and
you serve as good as that feels.
If feels just as good,
if not better,
to be paddling back out after
catching the wave and see my son just,
just,
just getting after it and it's so awesome.
It's like you sometimes you
sit there and watch, you know,
I'll just take the opposite
watching him and, and you try not,
you try to like contain yourself movie.
It's just so awesome. It's so cool. And,
and you know, you see, you know,
I got a bunch of daughters too
and seeing them do when they,
it basically when you see your kids
kicking acid stuff, man, it's man,
it makes you feel fucking good.
You know?
I mean you see them doing positive and
shit specially man, cause God knows,
I mean,
I've done so much negative shit.
They, when I see my kids doing something
positive makes me feel really good. Yeah.
Going back to the book, Talking About Your
Dad, my dad, my father died from a fire.
So you, your father, your father and
we didn't talk about it much. He,
he'd gone away and then he'd like,
had intermittent contact with you over
the years actually, once he was out. Yeah,
my life. I, you know, when my mom left
him when I was real young, you know,
uh, I never saw him again and I own, we
actually spoke to him twice on the phone.
I got like one letter from him and it
was like one or two pages and a cassette
of him playing guitar in
a halfway house. And, um,
basically just apologizing a lot.
And uh,
yeah, you know, he knew he made a lot
of bad choices, but, um,
that's fucked up though because you know
what I mean? Uh, he was all, you know,
he's fucked up on heroin and
he was an alcoholic. And, uh,
he, he actually, uh,
like kicked my mother in the stomach
when she was just like very pregnant with
me, you know? And, um, yeah,
that's how much he didn't want me.
So,
you know, it's a, it's a hard
pill to swallow, you know,
when your father would rather be strung
out on heroin then be your father.
But, uh, but I, I've managed to, uh,
turn it around, you know, cause, uh, I
love being with not just my kids, but I,
I teach the kids at the ends
up Gracie Academy. And, um,
so the childhood that
I didn't really have,
I get to experience and live vicariously
through all these other kids and I get
to be a role model to them.
Where as I didn't have any.
And you know,
I'm teaching these little boys and little
girls how to defend themselves and how
to fight,
not to fight and have honor and how to
lose with honor and always to shake their
opponent's hand and say,
good job.
Whether they win or whether they lose
and how to have that respect for their
opponent as well as themselves.
You know,
when I teach these kids that, you
know, there's like they say a Jujitsu,
there's no losing in Jujitsu.
You win or you learn.
And when I can take a kid who,
you know,
I've worked with a lot of
kids who have um, you know,
varying degrees of spectrum disorders
where there they've had autism or physical
issues and to see the
improvement that they make,
not just at Jujitsu but in,
uh,
in their social skills. Uh, you know,
kids who are so insecure that they won't
look at you and now they're making eye
contact with you,
talking to you to life,
change your face and
shaking your hand and,
and their chest is out and your shoulders
are back and they're not all, you know,
that,
you know.
So where I didn't have certain things,
you know,
at the end of the day it
gave me something else.
It gave me the ability to value that,
that relationship that you can have with
children that a lot of people take for
granted.
A lot of,
I even get disappointed with a lot of
the parents that bring their kids to
Jujitsu cause I feel like,
you know,
you're a lot of people hand their kids
off to everybody else to teach him how to
do everything. You know, they don't
work on stuff at home with them.
They don't sit there and teach
them. They don't. I get, you know,
when you have a kid that doesn't know
how to do a fucking jumping jack,
you're like, what the fuck
did your parents do with you?
They don't roll around with you. They
don't teach you how to do a somersault.
I have to teach you, which
is your left and your right
hand. Like really, you know,
I don't think people value
that time enough. And I have
said it before, it's like,
you know your, your, your job made,
your career may change
several times in your life.
Your spouse may not be your spouse for,
but your kids are always going to
be your kids. So you really have to
cherish and value that and the time
that you spend with them because they'll
always be your kids.
You know,
that woman that you think you're
in love with may leave you,
you may fall out of
love, your job May, uh,
you know the fold,
but your kids you to be your kids
forever and they'll always need you,
even if it's just emotionally
to know that you're there.
Even if they're not seeing you every
year or every six months or even if you
don't speak to them, they, you
know, you still have to be here
and emotional and spiritual
backbone even from afar.
You know, I had no, I mean, you know,
I forgive you dad.
Yup.
You,
uh,
yeah.
When he died,
you actually flew down to Texas to a
yeah. Basically the barrier,
the barrier and that,
that was cool too.
I got to finally meet his mother and,
and learn about my father's
side of the family.
So there was some
closure in that, but, uh,
I buried him myself. I, I wouldn't
let anybody throw dirt on top of him.
And, uh, and as it turned out,
I wound up marrying my mom too with my,
with my youngest son.
You're,
you're now,
you were kind of wrapping up this
book when you were writing it and,
and you know, you kind
of closed it out. Um, and
w when you closed it out, you, you
said this at the end of the book,
I guess part of being a father is learning
how to eat a certain amount of shit.
You do it for your kids
because they need you.
You just throw a little on a little salt
and pepper and maybe some Tabasco and
smile cause you gotta be there for them.
One thing my father said was,
I've got all these years of experience,
experiences that I don't
know what to do with.
And that's Kinda how I feel with my boys.
How do I come in for a graceful landing
after so much fucking turbulence in my
life?
Hopefully I can guide them better than
I was guided or at least maybe they will
learn from my mistakes.
God knows I've made enough for everybody.
And if I remember correctly,
you were,
that was the kind of the end of the book
and then you were moving on and then,
and then 2012 comes along and
there's like a hardcore fest, you know,
they're proud of bring it back. Like, oh,
I don't know if it's like a reunion fest,
bringing back a bunch of old bands and
the chromatics w I should say a formation
of the Cro mags or members of the
chromatics, you can just call it the
foam egg. So let's just keep it real.
They were going to play a fake ass band
that does my songs with one of the old
members, you know, and they
were going to play. Yes.
And you were like, okay, um, you know,
I'm gonna go check it out and you
know what? I'll bring my base.
Maybe we'll get onstage.
I mean, you know what?
There was actually two members of the
original group playing that night and my
intention was to go and
to extend my hand and say,
you know what guys? I
buried, I love you guys.
As much as I hate you.
I love you. You know,
and just because I like to think that at
the end of the day to people that were
friends can laugh at their
own foolishness. You know,
I would like to think that,
that people are able to look beyond their
egos and forgive each other for being
idiots because God knows we
all are at times. So yeah,
I went to that show with the hope of
maybe even being invited up on stage to
play a few songs with them. And
um, well the rest is history. Yeah.
You show up and, and here you go.
You're, you're walking through the place.
You go to the, you get invited up
the dressing room. Hey, come say hi.
And then here we go back to the book.
As soon as I walked in,
I literally walked into the room,
took two steps, the door shot,
and I got punched from behind
out of the corner of my eye.
Could see it with some big dude with
tattoos. It was like, Bam. He hit me hard.
I saw a bit of a flashbulb like you see
when you get hit out of nowhere and you
don't expect it.
And then it was a reign of fists and kicks
that were coming from every direction
of the room.
And this was a small room.
It's a dressing room and
I started falling forward.
I fell onto the couch and rolled onto my
back and started throwing up kicks just
instinctively to get people off me.
I was getting jumped by at least
four or five guys, probably more.
There was a bunch of people in the room.
I think I counted seven or eight,
although I couldn't even really
count in all the chaos at that point.
I reached into my pocket,
I had a little knife,
I pulled it out and it
still had its sheath on.
So I just tried to punch the first person
that was in front of me and get them
the fuck off me.
Everybody started screaming.
I saw the door of the dressing room open
and, and I started yelling, security,
security,
and then I left and then I saw somebody
pull the door shut and I thought to
myself,
fuck these dudes.
Their intention is to fuck me up and
they don't want no one to see it.
They're trying to beat the shit out of me.
And I've seen all these dudes in a pack
kicking people to the point where their
brains don't fucking work.
And I knew right then that if I didn't
get the fuck out of that situation,
I was not going to make
it home in one piece.
So I started flailing the
knife as furiously as I
could just to get myself the
fuck out of that situation
at toward the door,
everybody's screaming,
he's got a knife,
he's got a knife and I don't even know
who it was or how they ended up in my
face. I guess it was when
they were lunging at my arm.
I bet whoever was in front of my face,
I tore a big piece out of his cheek.
It was obvious. It was a setup.
When I saw the door pulled shut,
I was fighting for my life. These guys
wanted to kick the shit out of me,
stomped me out,
and no one would see it.
There would be no whist
witnesses and that would be that,
but that shit was not going down.
I bet the one guy's face,
I just tore his fucking cheat opened
right below his eye. He was screaming,
blood was running down his face.
I bet someone's wrist as they were
trying to get the knife out of my hand.
I just didn't bite it.
I tried to tear a piece out.
That's when the bouncers broken
to the room. At this point,
I was on the bottom of a pile trying
to stab and kick and everybody started
trying to grab my hand. They're like,
give me the knife, give me the knife.
I'm security. I ended up getting dragged
out onto the balcony getting kicked.
I got one good kick in the right face
and I'm surprised it did knock my teeth
out. One Dude's scream, get on
your stomach, get on your stomach,
put your hands out in front of you.
And this one big guy stepped on my back
with both of his feet and another guy
was looking at my face and squeezing my
throat. I don't know who the fuck was,
who. One guy looked at me
and said, motherfucker, I'll
kill you. I'll kill you.
I will kick you in your fucking face
until you are dead, motherfucker.
If you don't stop moving.
I saw Pete from sick of it all and the
crowd of people next to us with a freaked
out look on his face.
He was gesturing with his hands for
me to calm down and stop resisting.
He kept mouthing the words hardly
chill. Harley, please stop chill Harley.
That's when one guy said, put your
hands out in front of you. I asked her,
are you a cop? He was like, yeah.
So I said, show me your badge.
And at that point the boys in blue came
running up the stairs. I was like, fine,
I'm not moving any more cuff me.
I stuck my hands out in front
of me face down on the floor.
I still don't know that I've been stabbed.
I've got 40 stitches in my leg.
Thank God it was in my leg.
Only the cops cuffed me.
He turned me over and that's when I saw
the wound in my leg. It was grotesque.
The blood was bubbling out of it.
The fashion tendance were
literally hanging out on my leg.
That's why people started saying
that it was a compound fracture.
The cops cuffed me,
they put me on a chair,
carried me down the stairs
and put me in the ambulance.
It wasn't until I got cleaned up in the
ambulance that they realized it was a
stab wound.
Yeah,
it was a fun night.
And you kind of already talked about this.
I mean they basically arrest you
immediately was a total melee. Yeah,
and I actually won the,
I got arrested.
I thought we were all going
to get arrested and there
was this going to be like
a bar fight. Everybody you get
pulled in. But all these fucking guys
started making statements
that were basically,
that I've launched into
the room and started just
stabbing people. So, you know,
you got a room full of people saying
he did it, he did it, he did it.
And you got one of me saying,
what the fuck happened? Fuck,
he thinks is good and get walked out
in cuffs and you end up on Rikers,
Rikers island,
for those of you who don't know from
around the world is a jail in New York
jail, Rikers island.
And meanwhile the media,
you know, it's putting out all these, uh,
the version that's
getting told to the media,
which is that you instigated it and you
were a horrible person and et Cetera,
et cetera. And now you're out at Rikers
island, going back to the book all night.
You'd hear people
screaming and talking shit.
The youth offenders were in the
same building as us right next door.
So all night you'd hear them
screaming, suck my Dick, motherfucker,
I'll fuck you up. Suck
my dick son, but fuck,
oh fuck.
All night long.
Riot cops came in all
the all fucking night.
Then as soon as the sun would start
coming up and they'd finally shut up,
the seagulls would start making
noise. It was nonstop. Ironically,
it was the best sleep
I'd gotten in a while.
Ever since I started going
through the bullshit with my ex,
my life had truly become a nightmare.
I remember at one point I was looking
out through my window, through the gates.
It was a beautiful sunny day and I could
hear the birds and a butterfly flew
past my window and I was like,
damn, right then and there.
That butterfly represented freedom.
What I wouldn't do to be free right then.
I had no idea what it was going to happen.
My lawyer told me I was possibly
looking at two and a half years in jail.
Rough. Yeah, I remember
that butterfly very vividly.
Happy.
Yo
get that. You get that.
I don't want to pat.
It's also a prison was not in France.
Yeah,
it's like whatever islands. They were
all there. It was a prison. I went,
it was no joke,
man.
Prison as a no joke prisoner and you know,
we always find the good in things.
And you got a visitor that came to visit
a woman by the name of Laura.
Yes.
Who's now goes by the name
of Laura Lee Flanagan.
And uh, she was, she
had interviewed you for,
for what? For what website? Uh,
she had a website called
New York natives.com and,
um,
yeah,
they did a lot of stories
and then you know,
about things happening in the city and
interesting people in this and that and
blogs and stuff.
And she interviewed me as a,
a native icon, uh, because, um, you know,
you wouldn't know it from looking at
her and, or by her career. I mean,
she's a lawyer and she's, you
know, from the upper east side,
she's amazing. And, um,
she used to be in the hardcore for
a brief moment in her childhood,
so she knew of the chrome eggs.
She had seen us play. And,
um, a friend of hers, a, they were doing,
she did a story on c squat, a squat
that I used to live in, you know,
and um, it was really a good
story. It was very interesting.
And one of the people she
spoke to around that time said,
you should speak to Harley.
He used to live there and
he'd be interesting for you
know, for you to interview.
And she, uh, pursued it
and uh, we started talking,
um,
we did the interview and I started sending
her some chapters of this book that I
was still working on at the time.
And uh,
I don't remember how exactly
it came about. I mean,
she has a phd and she's done a lot of
writing and stuff in her life and a lot of
editing and stuff.
And she really enjoyed the book and I
needed some help in the editing. I mean,
I have a seventh grade education,
so there was,
the book was basically one sentence
when I gave it to her,
she gets the award for like
entity and challenges. No Shit.
I mean they were, it was better tonight.
I was like, yeah, you edited the book.
And then we, cause I was an English
major too and we had a moment of like,
I'm mute. I gave her a moment of
mutual respect and admiration.
I mean this book would it okay,
it's like 300 pages.
It would have been a thousand pages.
And it was like I said,
it was one sentence and we
literally had to like, okay,
we've got 10 stories about fighting
now can we lose these other 20 okay,
we've got 10 stories about
like almost overdosing.
Can we lose the other 30
okay. We've got, you know,
so there was a,
you know, I mean it would have
been a fucking endless book.
I mean I took a lot of fights and a
lot of drugs and a lot of rock and roll
dumbness and just a lot of actually
a good stories didn't make it in,
you know,
but I think,
I think we got left with a pretty
good picture of everything.
You know everybody, it's actually funny
because when I had the book signing,
a lot of people that I went to school
with and like fifth and sixth grade from
my neighborhood showed up and they
were like, dude, you nailed it man.
You described the neighborhood. So, and
the funny shit is actually one of the
hit men and the guys from my block was at
my book signing and I actually
asked him, I was like, dude,
who the fuck was pig man?
And he's like,
oh man, that was crazy. Eddie and
crazy. Eddie was a brand of PCP.
We all used to smoke back then. So I'm
sure that's why he got the nickname.
But um, he's like, yeah
man, you know, he's,
he's got an auto body shop down,
grandkids, blah, blah, blah,
like word, you know? I like, well
tell him I said, what's up? You know?
But it was funny because literally like
all that actually mattered more to me
than the reviews of the book was
when I had people who were shared,
those experiences and people
who grew up in the neighborhood.
I mean even more so than the cro mags,
parts of the books,
like the people who are like,
Yo, you fucking nailed it man.
This is exactly what the city was like.
I try to tell people all the
time and they don't get it.
So I bought them a copy just so
they can fucking see for themselves.
That was when I knew that I nailed
it. You know, that that was,
that was,
you know,
there was a couple of publishers
that didn't want to put
it out there. Like, yeah,
we can't touch this.
Like, Hey, you know how,
you know how your wife had to lose like
20 to fight stories and I had to do for
this podcast, I got
rid of their, you know,
we discussed a fraction of the
crazy shit that's in here. Nah,
I mean we haven't even touched,
I mean we could sit here and talk for
the fucking till tomorrow and you know,
but uh,
but I do, you know, I just, the book gets
it across and that's why like I said,
I thought I was familiar with
the hardcore scene and factually,
I mean I went to CBGBS,
I don't know,
hundreds of times when I was a kid and
all shows all over the east coast. Boston.
Yeah.
So,
but I still didn't recognize
that there was this much chaos
and speaking to chaos,
I'm going to go back to the book here.
You're sitting in jail and here we go.
Because all the people talking
shit and trying to frame me.
The record label I'd just signed
with was having second thoughts.
Everything was coming to a head and now
I had to prepare for a court date facing
four felony counts of second degree
assault and weapons charges for biting and
stabbing people.
If there was ever and I teach the kids.
If there was ever a time that
I was about to lose my shit,
I'd have to say it was around this time.
If there was ever a time someone
would relapse into drugs,
alcohol or some self destructive shit.
It was a time like this.
I actually went out and
got drunk a few nights,
which I hadn't done in a long time.
I was really depressed.
I was really at the bottom.
I could have easily spun out of control,
but I said to myself,
fuck that.
I'm not going to let myself go and do
that to myself or my kids or give in and
give the satisfaction to my enemies.
I'm a black belt.
I have more control than that now.
I'm not who I once was.
I'm stronger than that.
And then
the next court date I wound up getting
a d an adjournment again because they
didn't have a case against me.
And again,
it got pushed back while the DA continue
to try and build it until finally in
December of 2012 they contacted my lawyer
and said to appear in court on Friday,
December 14th when the
entire case was dismissed.
Yeah. And Yeah,
you
at that point, you know, you
kind of get back on track. Yeah.
And you're teaching Jujitsu like you said.
And there's a good quote here
when you're teaching Jujitsu,
after you had the incident at Webster
Hall and what are the parents said,
you know,
when into here he comes back to start
teaching the kids class again after he's
been all over the front page of all the
papers and everybody's looking at me
like,
oh shit.
I walked in the academy and like every
half the people were super happy to see
me in there. They have looked at me like
so like a gunslinger just walked in.
I was like, you know, fucking wild west.
One of them, one of the moms, one of
the moms was quoted as saying, well,
at least I know my kid isn't
getting taught Jujitsu by a pussy.
Yeah. That was why that fucking
data hands, Hanzo laugh.
And yet there's still,
um,
there's still hard times
because at this point you're,
you're losing custody of your kids. Yeah.
And that was, you know, that's, you know,
I gotta tell you it means
that has been the,
the biggest
trial and tribulation I've dealt with.
Obviously I've dealt with
many, but, uh, you know,
especially someone who didn't really have
responsible people like really
raising me. You know, I,
it really hurts to not be there
for your kids every day. You know,
cause I really, I used to cherish those
moments more than anything. I mean,
just walking them to school in the morning
and the little conversations we would
have on the way to school and,
you know,
okay.
Taking them to Jiu Jitsu and, you
know, I really was the, uh, this,
the main caretaker. I was with them all
day. You know, I did everything with them,
took them to the parks and
museums have this. That's isn't,
and to then have that taken away,
it's difficult to, again, to not
start fucking up, you know,
especially when you're
dealing with depression and
all that shit again. You know,
it's just like, uh, like I said, you know,
we don't have someone to
love and to feel that,
that reciprocation and, and, uh,
you don't feel needed. It's hard
to not feel needed, you know.
But I, uh, all right. You know,
I went through all the process of
family court and this and that, and, uh,
you know, unfortunately they don't live
with me full time, but I see them a lot.
And, um, you know, everybody knows who's
been through a divorce and as kids, right?
Fortunately, I was never married to
their mother. Hallelujah. But, um,
anybody who's been in
that situation knows it's,
it's not easy and it comes with
a lot of challenges. And, uh,
so now my challenge is,
is to try to
be involved with my kids'
lives as much as I can and to,
to try to give them some moral
guidance and a manhood guidance from,
from a distance, you know, and
sadly, they didn't see, you know,
me and their mother act like complete
and total savages towards the end of the
relationship because people,
when they break up,
they typically don't know how to act
or behave even in front of their kids.
So,
but you know what,
even all of this is made me a stronger
and wiser person because I feel that it
has again forced me to look at myself.
And,
uh,
you have choices in every situation,
how you're going to react and how you,
you know,
what you're going to do.
And now I really think about
the consequences of everything.
I know I can't just react
explosively if somebody
does or says something to me on the
street because I know that that could cost
me my freedom.
It could cost that my kids,
their father could cause
my wife or husband. So,
you know,
even
even losing my kids has been a
learning experience that I hope,
God forbid, they ever,
you know, wind up, um,
with kids in separated and this and that.
But hopefully even this bad stuff can
help them become better men and smarter
men and hopefully better,
smarter than I was,
you know? And uh, I just try to,
I try to believe really that, that
in the end love wins, you know?
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
There were,
so one more thing that you
had to overcome in the book
and you know, sometimes, man,
I just read a big chunk of the books
that I'm reviewing because it's just,
uh, uh, uh, the way it's written in a
way it goes and the story that it tells,
I just don't really want to change it.
I just want to put it out there.
So I'm Kinda gonna do that right here.
After all the madness in my life and the
recent drama surrounding Webster Hall,
my arrest, losing my kids,
starting a new relationship,
getting my kids back in my
life and dealing with all
the drama of family court.
My mom was stricken with terminal cancer.
Okay.
After a major operation in
what seemed like a recovery,
things took a turn for the worse.
Okay.
Through it all,
she remained supportive in my battle
for my kids and I started spending a lot
more time with her.
It's fucked up when you know
your mom or dad is dying.
Okay.
You go through your whole life with all
the baggage and shit that they put on
you and all the shit in the world and
your friends put on you and then there
comes a time when you realize
you have to put it all down.
Yeah.
Then just let it all go.
I was with her as much as possible
during the last few months.
We spent more time together than we had
in years. We even left the city one day,
just a month before she died to
spend some time at a horse stable.
She loved horses and she hadn't been
around them since she was a child.
She said it was the most
beautiful day in her entire life,
and later she spent the night and then
the next three nights at my apartment,
we had such a good time that
she completely forgot to
take her pain medication.
I hope I can face death with as much
dignity the way she has handled it.
I've never seen a braver
person in my life.
She makes all the men I
know look like cowards.
Okay.
Sadly, she only saw my kids
twice during her last few months,
but the time that they spent together was
amazing and very meaningful and picked
up her spirits.
Okay.
And I don't know.
And I know that she took great comfort
in the fact that I'm finally in a place
in my life where things are
coming together in a positive way.
Okay.
I just wish she could have
been here with us longer.
Yeah.
She died Monday, June 15th, 2015
okay.
At the funeral, her ashes were
carried out and placed on a table.
Okay.
They weren't a box.
Not meant to be buried.
A beautiful statue of a crying angel.
Yeah.
We all took part in
reading from Bible verses.
I held onto my son, Jonah,
and he cried quietly.
My son hardly stood behind me
with my girlfriend trying to
keep his composure.
As tears rolled down his face
at the end of the service,
a slight drizzle of rain started again.
When everyone was done consoling each
other and people started walking away.
I looked at the box sitting on the table
surrounded by flowers with the hole in
the ground beside it.
Yeah,
to cemetery workers arrived with shovels
and a rake and I walked back and asked
if I could cover her with soil
myself as I don't from my father.
13 years earlier,
I explained that I didn't feel right
about someone who didn't know my mother
covering her with dirt.
Yeah,
they understood.
Okay.
I thank them. I took the box
with the angel off the table.
I kissed it.
My son's kissed it and I got down on
my knees and put it in the ground.
I wonder. The cemetery workers handed me
a shovel and I started to fill the hole.
My youngest son who'd been
crying came over next to me.
Got on his knees and started to help
me fill the hole with his hands,
grabbing pieces of soil
and putting them in,
picking out rocks so none would
damage her box as we filled it.
Okay.
And his tears stopped.
I put down the shovel and we both
finished by hand and then I raked the soil
over and we pat it down the earth
with our hands and it was done.
It was so sad and so beautiful.
The next day was father's day.
Okay.
When I started writing this book,
I didn't know what the end was going
to be or what I wanted to say besides
telling the story of my life
and setting the record straight.
But now it's so obvious what is about
closure
and that
that wraps up the book.
Yeah.
And
look,
no one has lived a perfect life.
We've all made mistakes. We've all
done things that can't be on dawn,
and we've gone places
that we should not have
gone,
but we all have the opportunity
to redeem ourselves.
And it starts with
confessing what we've done.
It starts with owning it and then getting
on the right path and staying on the
right path
and staying on that path,
the correct path.
It takes discipline and it takes humility
and it takes courage and it's hard,
but
what is the other choice?
What else can we do?
Let the darkness completely consume us.
Live for instant gratification.
Wherever we can find it.
Be over taken
by temptation.
Advice.
No,
do not accept that.
I,
I hear from a lot of people that
struggle with all these things.
They're caught,
they're drowning.
Okay?
They're folding under the weight of pain
and suffering and misery and addiction
and they asked me what I think.
Well, what I think Nan,
what Harley proves is that
you are better than that.
You are better and you can try
on flow over these dark forces.
You can become better.
You can be better
for yourself and for
the people around you.
For all of us,
hold the line,
stay clean,
okay.
And never surrender.
You overcame a lot of stuff,
man.
I
have and I'm still trying,
you know?
Yeah,
I guess everyone is.
Yeah.
This is the time in the podcast.
Why we have that coherence.
One of the many reasons
because where do we get a
chance to decompress a little
bit. Yes. Fully, fully.
He gets to ask a couple questions. It
plagued my mind a little quick. Yeah.
You know, like when after the
thing where'd they stop wearing
and my leg. Um, I mean
it's, you can see when I was
oh yeah, yeah. Like
lower lake. Yeah. Yeah.
Cause you were saying the thought or
they thought it was a compound fracture.
Yeah. Cause you know Fisher is white.
Yeah. Yeah. Right. Tagging out.
So everybody thought that was
bowling. It was sticking out. Yeah.
That it make sense down there. But kind
of by your Shin, like in your thigh,
be like compound fracture that yeah.
No,
I didn't even know it happened until I
was coughed on the floor or I'll see it.
And that's so crazy. Like when
you're in the moment so much. Yeah.
Well you can get straight up, stab,
stab with your stuff, hanging out,
going to be hanging off and you'd
be like, okay, what's next? Okay.
Oh, is that all my cases off all day?
Oh, can I help you? Here's your eyeball.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean that's why,
that's why I'm so sketchy when it
comes to like, as much as I, you know,
I got admitted like that shit was fun.
I like a good adrenaline.
It's like a,
a good violent confrontation.
Look,
good fight is fun,
but
it was also like life and death,
you know? So it's like, you know,
like I was saying, you know,
like I had that one fight and California
where I'm running into a mob of all
these dudes. Like, you know, I was
high off that shit for like a week.
My adrenaline,
it's like, ah, I felt like
I could fucking raw. Yeah.
And then like a week later, I'm like, what
the fuck man? Yeah. What was that shit?
You know?
So like
as much as you know. Yeah. It was fun.
How often do you get to have a
street fight anymore? You know, Shit.
Especially at my age.
You guys, good time, man. But
it was all the other shit,
all the fucking ripple effects
that came along. We're like, fuck,
I may not see my kids. Fuck, I may be
in jail. Fuck of the next three years.
Like fucking, you know, protecting
my ass for bubbles over here. Yeah.
I'm like fucking, you know, those shit
was like, damn man, can we forget Kate,
we just all get along. Okay. We all
just have a street fight, you know,
and just like, can't we all just have
a Steve ride get on with our Shit,
you know?
But you know, but you know, shit
happens man. We going to do man. Yeah.
When you put everything into perspective,
the whole getting into street
fights doesn't seem quite
as dope. Yeah. You know,
it changes when you got responsibilities.
That's the thing.
The responsibilities anyway.
Speaking a responsibility,
responsibility. We're not
getting any younger. Um,
so we'll talk about on at first as always.
Um,
so on it supplements, you
know, you know, but on it, no,
most people use just to know, but
on oh, and the west coast, they do.
I think that's how you mother fuckers,
you are [inaudible] need to get on it.
Yo.
Yo what the fuck is up with on it?
True.
But here endure.
And that's what I thought too with
supplements where it's like, yeah,
it takes up him until they get you big.
I found that that's not
necessarily the case.
So the supplements that I take the we
take, therefore like you got a suitcase,
which I'm in him.
I'll get you [inaudible]
been on other shit.
[inaudible] this is stuff that's good.
This is legal.
I want you to be on the right stuff
towards the light.
The light is on it.
You know how like, like
for example, the one,
the ones that I take,
we take now because Krill oil
for inflammation and shit like that.
You're exactly right.
So the so on, it is like a real reputable
company that, um, like, you know,
you're getting,
because right,
you can get supplements and you're
getting like they say a Krill and you're
getting like fucking,
you know,
rat Rach bladder oil or some shit,
you know? And they'll be like, yeah,
that's cool.
Yeah.
The rest of it's own vitamin
e Joe. Yes, exactly. Right.
So this is like known to be the best.
I'm going to have to get down. Actually
I'll read the, you know the main guy,
his like he has an extensive
background in like uptake.
You know how like you can get a calcium
supplement but that supplement won't
deliver the uptake so your body doesn't
deny even breaking it down or absorbing
it. Yes, exactly. So this only snow,
there's a lot of different
vitamins and all that shit. I,
I tried to get all my vitamins
through food. Yes. You know,
if I can, you know. Yeah, that's optimal.
So that's kind of the point there were
like, yeah, when you get it with food,
you know that you're going to get the
best uptake for the most part. You know,
if you, if you're getting
your, you know, I dunno,
protein from soy beans or
something, you know, something,
I don't get as much protein as you
animals over here. I'm a vegetarian.
I have been since like 82
or something like that,
which I also think is one of the reasons
why I managed to maintain a certain
level of health and sanity
despite all the drugs.
I think that that actually,
you know, helped me.
The wheat grass [inaudible] hey,
hey,
everyone was listening to a podcast.
If you're shooting up heroin
and always wear a condom when
you're shooting your hair. Yes,
good Lord. Well, yeah, you figure
that's optimal from the food,
but on it like they like Vaco.
Good job
in knowing like the optimum way to
uptake. Like the nutrients. Yeah,
I found that out nice. That's like,
you know, I was like, you know,
that's a good one. Anyway, one of the
reasons. So we do krill oil, strong bone,
new one. I just started. Jack always
does it for your, for your joints.
So you do know I have some joint
issues after a while. That's how,
and yeah, the, and the crude oil
helps a lot. A lot. A lot. That's the,
I'd say that's the number
one that I would recommend.
I'd recommend a few more other things too,
but just for different reasons.
Like to have this one warrior Bart's buff
while you're vegetarian, so nevermind.
Buffalo, buffalo meat. Maybe.
You know how like they make
not necessarily no buffalo
meats better for you?
I mean, I know you know it doesn't
have all the fucking hormones.
I don't know if you can
necessarily offer it to the God.
Sorry, which God you're
offering it to. I mean,
I'm sure there's some native American
guy does a lot of the warrior bars
to
fear Hindu.
There's enough guys to
pick from and I got plenty.
Yeah, I think they'd be done
for the shroom tech as well,
which is stuff it's made from a mushroom,
the mushroom name,
different kinds of mushrooms
I was doing on
the board started to sound good,
but it's just to help you uptake oxygen
when you do with athletics. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
You need to, especially as you get older,
your oxygen, it doesn't travel as well.
I just realized there's no greater joy
for echo. Then when someone's on the,
on the, on the podcast as a guest
that wants to know about this stuff,
like when I'm training or whatever oil
is it like you know your thing and I'm
like doing a sales pitch to
them. It seems like it. Anyway,
get them a krill shirt.
I asked me about the Krill oil.
I'm telling you in the mornings,
I told this story before,
Jack heard it plenty of times in
the mornings. My daughter, she's,
she's like for now, but you know when
she was three she come in, wake me up.
The only person in the world that hasn't
heard the story is Harley Fun. Yeah.
[inaudible] and me talk for
three hours right there.
Heck gets to talk for an hour now about
story.
And that was a good,
but she'd, she'd wake me up,
jump on my back. So you know,
now I've got to stand up out of bed,
cold,
sore from whatever with the three year
old on my back and it would be stiff.
I got to do the correct form to get up.
Otherwise, you know, you turn your back,
your knees, all that stuff after like
it was just under a week. Krill oil,
no factor. It's like I was
already warm. That's the feeling.
You want some Krill oil now.
I was just going to
Jack. I got to give my, uh, father-in-law
some props. May he rest in peace.
He turned me onto the Krill.
Oh, all right. Let me
tell you other than laws,
but what's up filing laws?
They've been around,
been around a little longer than
us. Yeah. No, he turned me on and,
and even though you know, I am a
vegetarian, I do take the official,
the Krill oil and whatnot, because
you know what I mean? Look, I,
I started off as a vegetarian food for
whatever spiritual reasons and whatever
health reasons.
Now I,
I believe it's best to have
mainly vegetarian diet,
but if my body starts
saying, motherfucker, he
needed some fish like you,
you are like about to drop dead. If you
don't get some serious protein search,
like I will do what I,
what my body tells me to do.
I think humans are designed to be
able to do vegetarian and meat.
That's why we have two different
kinds of teeth. You know,
when we were hunter gatherers,
you know you were gathering a lot more
than you were hunting realistically.
Cause one thing wasn't always easy with
a fucking spear, you know, so yeah.
You know, I listen to my body a lot too
and my body usually tells me each day,
you know crops total pro.
Well the good thing about the Krill,
whether this meat however much this means,
how they harvest the Krill is also yes.
Do it though.
It's good.
They use like ecofriendly chips.
He watched the video friendly
shifts [inaudible] no friendly shit.
Fuck it up the video.
I watched the video is good.
Okay. Maybe you just need to have their
own podcast called the echo on it.
Podcast. People need to know. You
got to fucking make your own line.
Eco Oil something. I don't
know man. It's hot it one.
I think they haven't nailed it. All
right on it. I'm going to get on it.
Interesting enough how your
father in law turned up.
My father in law turned me onto it.
I didn't listen to him, by the way.
I only did it when Jocko was like, yeah,
I take Krill oil. So I was like, okay,
I'm going to take whatever. Anyway.
Anyway,
[inaudible] dot com slash Jocko that's
how you can get 10% off of all your stuff.
Whatever you like. Well, I'm just going
to ask him directly gave me the tech.
That's what I did in the
beginning to for sure. Yeah.
Also good way to support Amazon.
Click through. So what all that is,
you shop on Amazon,
right?
I guess I have how I just said you're the
only person that hadn't heard like the
Krill oil,
so now you're the only person in the
world does not getting everything they buy
off of Amazon. Oh, I live in
the city. I go to the store,
I guess isn't different. Yeah, we want it.
We go out and close the door and get it.
You can walk. Yeah, you can
walk everywhere. Yeah. It's
not like that. Like I said,
we got yards and barbecues and yards.
Fuck y'all motherfuckers all miserable.
No winter jazz. Mother fuckers. No snow,
nothing gets study. We have a winter.
Was He? You know he's from Hawaii.
He takes it from California.
Goes one step further.
My mom says that,
oh yeah,
in the winter it rains a lip or I don't
even know if that's true reins a little.
That shit that don't qualify as
[inaudible] mean it feeds the plants.
You know it's a fucking mind soon.
I don't want to hear it. Yeah man.
I hear bad things. Bad things. So Amazon,
Amazon, all these things you've turned to
me shopping on Amazon and this goes for
everyone. Before you get to animal,
you click through the website,
our website, your website support.
So when you bought you get a thing from
Amazon saying hey, thanks for referring.
You know it's pretty,
that's pretty dope.
They give us a little bit a little piece
of that and you know what it costs the
Vick. The cool thing is, cause you can
set up things for, for like podcasts,
that's basically give me money,
give me money.
But I don't really like asking people
for money. This is, you don't even,
it doesn't, your price doesn't
go up. It's actually in my book,
it's kind of a good way to stick it to
the man because Amazon's got a kick a
little bit down to the
podcast are over here.
It's kind of not because I mean you
stick it to the man to [inaudible] fucked
man.
Yeah, a little bit of confusion there.
That's cool. But I mean either way,
you know when you do the, I think it does
benefit Amazon cause like a referral,
you know,
I mean,
so you're saying that somebody might
order something from another online
retailer but instead someone says I'm
going to support the podcast. Yeah,
fuck that. Support the podcast.
Motherfucker. Don't be a bunch of bitches.
You gotta support the home team,
man. Fuck that. I feel the same
shit. But Amazon is actually
pretty cool like that.
Like they'll offer every once in
a while like little things like,
oh you want to donate?
Like you round up. Like,
let's say your thing costed like eight
89 and you're like, Hey, your gut,
11 cents to the next dollar, you want to
donate that 11 cents to like something,
it's like charity anyway. It's good like
that. Anyway, and I support the podcast,
do through the Amazon, click through,
go to the Jocko podcast website,
which is Jocko podcast.com and click
on the support or the Amazon banner and
then do your shopping. And
that's a good way. Some people,
they'll do it and then like the little,
they'll get a screenshot of it and they'll
send it to me on Twitter knowing that
that is cool. That is dope. It's
confirmation. Yeah. And it's Kinda like,
like they say, Hey, I'm
supporting them and I feel,
I feel that like literal direct
support from their coach Charles A.
Good day as your support, the podcast
with a little social needs when,
cause I got, a lot of times they don't, I
don't see like the price or nothing. You,
they'll just say, oh, it'll be
a screenshot. Pretty ambiguous.
It could very well not even be them.
So putting the podcast necessarily call.
Yeah. Just trying to tickle your did
that. Maybe it works. It works out.
Like when they do that makes me feel good.
I feel like they care very easy.
Easy. Anyway. You can
subscribe to the podcast,
iTunes if you listen to it on iTunes,
stitcher, Google, play, all these ones.
Um, yeah, that helps leave a
review. If you're in the mood,
like what chuck was saying,
or hardly seems like you don't give
a review on this specific one. Oh,
we have a youtube channel. If you
have not subscribed to that, good.
Subscribe to that.
If,
if you'd like the video version of this
podcast, but the excerpts, you know,
people have been kind of giving me
crap about saint excerpts a lot too.
I say excerpts.
You say it a lot and you
put your tone on it for you.
Don't just say, I don't think he said
no. You don't say, Hey, you know,
we've got some excerpts that we put
on it. You Go, I made a couple extra.
You Go, you go. Escalation
voice level 12. Yes.
Well I think that was your right? Was that
your idea? Excerpts? Yeah. There you go.
Yeah, because people don't want to
watch TV. They're not going to watch it.
Three hours, three hour podcast. If
there's some point, oh hey Joe glue.
Cool thing with Harley Flanagan.
He was talking about this.
They want to see Harley for three minutes.
I want to send it to their body
that they listen to hardcore with.
They can't send them, hey, watch this
three and a half hour podcast in the next,
during your lunch break, you're going
to send him a little clip, right?
Listen to Harley Flanagan. Talk about a
street fight. Yeah, yeah, exactly right.
Maybe you should do a bunch of excerpts
of yourself talking about on it and
extra next to me. Seen excerpts.
Yeah, that's not very shareable,
but that was a good idea.
Thank you Jacqueline for that.
So if you want to see excerpts of random
lessons, not random, they're not random.
Sorry, any mean random excerpts of
lessons, individual lessons selected,
selected from the podcast. Boom. That's
on youtube. And also if you want one,
tell echo on social media.
Hey,
make this time period on this podcast
into an excerpt and put me on there too,
because that way I can harass him too. Now
we can't do to every single one. Quest.
Yes.
Straight to every single one.
But some of them icy and I
go, yeah, Echo. Come on man.
The nickel are asking. I agree. Could
you post the wheat grass and heroin?
That'd be a fun one. I think we're gonna.
I think we're going to do that one.
But
we'll have tee shirt
[inaudible]
cause everybody, that's another
thing, they want extroverts,
but people also want to have
tee shirts for everything.
Like anything that some person where
somebody finds something funny or
interesting or whatever and it's, hey,
we need to make that into a teacher.
And then it gets escalated to a certain
point where enough people ask for it and
then we break down. You should go
breaks down and makes a teacher.
It works too. It's like a
Oh yeah, it's good. Yeah.
It's so the excerpts. Good
idea. Thank you. Uh, Youtube.
But if you do the request,
if you're requesting that the,
you know what episode and what
x or be sure you know which,
which excerpts are already on there.
Cause sometimes people are like, Hey,
do this London and then it'll already
be on there just saying. Yeah.
Sometimes people tell me to
do a book review and it's
already been done. Oh yeah.
If you're doing a review on art of war,
yeah, I get a lot of requests like that.
Then I have to look up and see which one
it is and then send it back to him and
say, hey man, I already
did it on this one. Yeah.
Actually that's a good like
how we're going over today.
That's a good thing about how we put the,
the timestamps on all the subjects.
So an and that feeds into the search
term. So if you, you're like, hey,
some suit Jocko podcasts are devor it'll
go boom to that episode 23 actually
coming on top of this book,
there's a book out about HR
right now from the bad brains.
And the reason I'm thinking of this is
because one of my buddies who's in to the
podcast who was a hardcore kid growing up,
and his name is Nahko,
but he's a,
he's a cop in La and he
was a cop in New York.
And so it's,
I'm just thinking about that.
Here's a kid that grew up listening to
the cro mags, who's been like saying,
get hardly or you got to get her,
he's a cop.
He's a bad ass cop and his and his girl
was a cop too. Dang. They're getting,
after I got to phrase that
cops, man, don't hate them all.
You know people, they'll be
like, hey, no, I don't eat carbs.
I have friends that are cops.
Some of my best friends are black.
I got a cough Capo,
my phone.
Fuck No. Oh good. I'm also, hey,
Jocko has a store. It's called Jocko
store. These shirts, stucco. We're man,
I need to get one of these discipline
equals freedom. The fucking shirts.
You know, I wrote a song recently
that I named discipline equals freedom
and just I got
to fucking say,
because you know I don't give a fuck,
I'm going to say it and that's that.
Yo,
when I found out that Jocko was in the
hardcore and when I found out that he was
into my band, the Cro Mags, I was,
I was very proud and all and uh,
and I asked this motherfucker, you give
a thought about singing in her heart
and fucking reaction I
got out of this month
fucker.
If my computer screen could like just
turn into like a fucking screaming look.
Motherfucking the, the,
the the response. Anyway,
I am very proud to say that a w w we are
going to be playing besides doing this
European tour. I'm going away in
a week playing all over the place.
Then we'll come back and in June I'm
going to be playing in La and we have
invited Jocko to come and make a special
guest appearance when we play it,
the fury fest in La.
And so for all you motherfuckers out
there who want to see me playing with one
of the baddest motherfuckers walking
this fucking earth certified by the u s
fucking government,
then you,
you were going to see some fucking Badass
shit because I'll tell you I have not
gotten, I haven't been able to just play
the bass and not be like chained to the
microphone in a really long time.
And that was one of the things that was
intense about the cro mags back in the
old days was that me and the singer
both used to go fucking ape shit when we
played. And it's funny cause you know I
was thinking for the longest time man,
if I could get a singer what I get and I'm
like, you know shit, I'm like, I'm like,
you know Henry Rollins in his
prime was fucking bad ass.
You know Phil Anselmo in his
prime was a fucking bad ass
jock.
So we'll see what happens if
[inaudible] want to see some shit.
You know, I used to have a fake seal
thing in my band. Now I get a real one.
We'll see what happens if a,
if a Mike ends up in my hands,
I may have to slap them with
a mic and see what happens.
Hey, there you go. Yeah, you guys
can sing the or with those shirts on
[inaudible] story. That's where you get
them. I got you. Whatever shirt you need.
Oh yeah, for sure. But if you're
in the mood to support the podcast,
purchase a shirt or whatever,
we have other stuff on
there. Jocko. Story, outcome.
Got Those mugs you made. Yeah,
those are some good monks.
So I shouldn't have even said this.
He's been amped about these brew coffee
mugs we got or what did he called?
Travel mugs. Travel mugs. Tumblers.
I've heard. Yeah. All right. Look,
I won't go that deep into it this time.
Next time I'm going deep extra deep.
This time I'll go. Just kind of deep.
This is straight up the best cup of it,
right? What does it look?
It look like his head,
like a handle on it.
Actually we kept a little bit,
you know, it's just black on black. It's
like black matte and then the design,
you know, it looks like this on one
side, then it's shiny black anyway,
it looks super dope,
but 30 ounces so big enough but small
enough to fit in your cup holder.
Boom. I, I'd been drinking
some mother fucking coffee. So,
so here's the thing about the coffee,
it's,
it's those ones that are like, I
dunno how they make them, you know,
the insight and the, I dunno,
they're stainless steel, BPA
free, all this, you know,
good stuff. I don't know what all of
that means, but it's, I know it's dope.
It's Krill involved. Yeah,
it's somewhere down. The line
is involved, but it keeps it like
your car. If you like your coffee hot,
it'll keep it hot for like eight
hours or something like that.
I don't know if it keeps it the same
temperature for eight hours. It might,
I don't know. I've never had hot,
I'm a cold coffee guy. All right,
well here's the good news about that
Bro. But you put quit. How's this?
I put ice water in it and
I was drinking it a drink.
Like almost all of it.
There was still a little bit in
the bottom and I forgot about it.
Went to sleep the next day I
was cleaning up. I was like,
oh my cup from last night.
Boom, ice still in there.
You know how usually in a
regular cup it's like water.
It'll keep it cold for 24 hours.
Boom. Not losing any coldness.
Anyway, I want to go way deeper next
time, but this is straight, you know,
special podcast for you to talk about
that. That Cup or bowl out group covered.
One episode will be the cop.
The other episode will be the oil oil.
Every single day.
I'll go deeper with the oil bro.
I'll go deeper with the Krill oil
right now if we have, I know it all,
but anyway,
essentially what it is anyway, but
yeah, but yeah, chocolate star,
this some cool stuff on their
travel mugs are out. Those are good.
There's some bumper stickers, some
women's stuff on there, some patches,
some rash guards, one new rash guard, and
it's not, it'll be out, but nonetheless,
I'm not going to promise anything quite
yet, but new rash guards going to be out.
Hoodies are on there.
There's some good stuff. Hey,
just take a look if you like what's on
there. You want to support in that way.
Get something also psychological warfare.
Okay.
All right. Hardly might not know about
psychological war for so many. Explain it.
Go deep. None. Not that deep.
So basically it's an album.
We're three hours and 18 minutes
into this quick. All right.
It's an album echo.
Don't care. Don't care.
Don't care if the hours
and keep listening. No,
I'm just saying this part is kind of
important too. You know what I mean?
People are out there getting after
it, waking up early. Some people,
some of us sticking to the program,
sticking to the Diet,
sticking to the workouts,
right?
Every once in a while you wake up or
you don't feel like waking up early that
day or you don't feel like working
out that day, you're kind of tired.
You had a hard day, whatever. So when
it's time to it, when it's go time,
you're like, Hey, maybe I'll skip today.
You know when you sleeping on the program,
I know that feeling
where you skip your wheat grass.
Exactly right.
So Bam, get this album called
psychological warfare to Jocko. It's not,
it's not music.
It's just tracks with Jocko telling you
how to overcome those weak moments in
your program. Oh boy. But it's him telling
when I, when I am having a weak moment,
the last thing I want to fucking hear,
telling me to get after it
right now I got to do that.
Fuck, it's four o'clock.
Can we fuck another four
hours? Fuck me. You know,
I like sleep. I don't know what the fuck
is wrong with you guys, but whatever.
It's all good. Yeah. Hey
Man, I'm sure I like dreams.
No, actually I don't. Sleep is the enemy.
It's like a,
it's like the last hallucinogenic.
I can take [inaudible] dream.
My brain goes bananas.
Love it.
Okay, I get it. But it goes for
the workup stuff too though.
Not just asleep so you can skip the
sleep ones. So you go, but like,
like the workout went until tell you
don't skip the word anyway. It's a good,
very helpful,
a hundred percent chance of success.
But Dolan, good psychological
warfare. And uh,
also by the way,
when you click through Amazon,
you can click through and you
can buy this book right here.
The book is called
hardcore life of my own.
It is written by Harley Flanagan
and we'll have it up on the website.
But let me rephrase that. It's on the
website or are we waiting to be purchased?
And there you go pick it up on Amazon.
You can also get some Jocko white tea.
I hear now there's some things in the
book that Harley does not recommend.
He, he, he's tried them,
but he does not recommend some of those
things that he clearly states in the
book. He literally says,
I do not recommend. For
instance, I do not recommend
angel dust. I do not
recommend heroin. I do not.
So there's a lot of things
he doesn't recommend.
Now here's something that I will
strongly recommend as Jocko white tea.
It's gonna get you a lot
better results than anything.
Any of the supplements that that
Harley's taken in this book.
You go with Jocko white tea instead,
you're going to have a much better trip.
I'm going to tell you that right now.
Also,
we talked a lot about Jujitsu today and
we talk about Jujitsu a lot. You know,
Jujitsu is a big,
you know,
Jujitsu is a powerful thing and there's
a book that's out right now and it's
geared, it's written kind of written for
kids. It's called way of the warrior kid.
It's available. Everyone that's
bought it already. Thank you.
I appreciate the support.
Thanks for spreading the word.
Thanks for letting kids get
a little insight into life.
And I'll tell you,
there's something about this book that is,
when I wrote it,
the the debt, the father, the book
is about a kid who's, you know,
fifth grade going through life.
The father in the book
doesn't have a role.
Now you might think I'm a bad person
for not giving the father the role,
but you know,
they all,
he says that there's one line about
the father and the book, He says,
my dad's gone a lot with work and stuff.
It's that ambiguous.
And, and there's a couple
reasons why I did that.
And the number one reason is because not
everyone, not every kid has got a dad.
I mean, what you're saying is
actually very real. Yeah. You know,
and a lot of kids have to
just deal with, uh, yeah,
my father is not around
much. Yeah. You know, and,
and that's why I did it.
And,
and there's another subtle
reason and you know,
without going into too much crazy detail,
the lead character in the book,
his name is mark,
and he's actually named after Mark Lee,
who was one of my guys,
were just an incredible,
incredible person,
incredible warrior.
And he was killed in Iraq and you know,
he was,
he, he didn't have a dad. His
mom raised him and you know,
so it was my way of saying, look,
you know, not everyone has a dad.
And, and in the book, he's got a strong
uncle that comes in and helps him.
But at the end of the book is uncle
points out to them and he says,
who's going to help me now? And
his uncle says to him, look,
you don't need to,
you know what the right things to do are.
You know how to stay on the right path.
You don't need someone to
hold your hand all the time.
You can make this happen for yourself.
And that's the message, you know,
that I'm trying to get across to
kids that might not have a dad.
They might not have an uncle,
they might not have a mom.
But you can find out what the
right path is. You can get on it,
you can stay on it. And that's, that's
why I wrote the book that way. And,
and you know,
it's,
it's interesting cause I've gotten asked
many times over the years, you know,
about what do you think
about fatherhood and,
and the important roles that fathers
play. And again, you know, I go back to,
for instance,
Mark Lee's a great example of a kid that
was raised and have a dad and his mom's
a strong woman in a and an incredible
person and she raised a warrior.
So that's why I did that in that book.
And you know,
another thing that I did in that book is,
you know,
Jujitsu plays a prominent role,
but you could replace that with wrestling,
with boxing, with, with Moitai.
But jujitsu was really a big part of it.
But so is studying,
you know, um, learning, learning
how to learn and having, and,
and as a kid,
seeing what the opportunity is in
being educated because a lot of kids,
myself included,
when you're going to school,
when you're 10 years old or 15 years
old, you don't care. You just don't care.
And it's,
I want,
I want kids to realize that it's
beneficial to get stronger, faster,
smarter and better.
So that's a way of the war.
Your kid get it and get it for your
local library too because they need it.
Cause there's some kid that will grab
that book in the library and it'll get
them on the right path. Also,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
You can find it by itself in the get
after its section of any bookstore or
online book retailer.
If you look in the get after at section,
this is a big empty shelf.
There's a one book there,
it's called discipline
equals freedom field manual.
We had start petitioning now
to make that happen at Amazon.
They just need like when you drop down
business lifestyle, health and fitness,
get out,
boom.
There's that one book they'd
better get in the game and
also there's extreme ownership.
The book that kind of started all of this
stuff by the way. Thanks. Appreciate it.
It's about leadership and it's about
combat and it's about taking fucking
responsibility and it's about
taking responsibility. Absolutely.
That's fucking huge. Yeah, that's huge.
That's something that I think is one of
the hardest things for most people to
do.
And you know,
I actually highlighted that a bunch of
times in your book where you're kind of
explaining things that I guess you
would say maybe resulted in something
happening bad in your life and you'd say,
Hey,
this happened and this
happened and this happened.
And every time you went laid that out,
at the end of it you'd say,
but it's my fault and I should have
done, I, I made this happen to myself.
So it's pretty, uh, and,
and you wrote this book before we
probably writing this to say, you know,
you were writing this book,
the same tower is right in that book when
I was basically fucking trying to kill
myself with drugs and everything
else is when I started it.
And even in that state, you always
say, you know, it's my fault.
I should've, you know, hey
my, my dad wasn't around.
Make a habit out of looking for
other people to blame. I mean, it's,
it's important to identify the
roots of the problem and so on.
And what made you the way you
are so you can fix them. Exactly.
Exactly.
And a big,
a big part of being a man is accepting
responsibility for your fuck ups.
And I thought that was awesome.
You know, and again, you know, um,
when you were talking about what you
learned from your dad not being around and
then how you apply that to help other
kids that are in that situation,
teaching them to Jitsu and taking care
of him and be building relationships the
best you can with your kids and with
other kids that are around. Man, that's,
that's exactly what you're talking about.
So that's extreme ownership
and also don't hoard the knowledge.
You might think, hey, I'm going to
get extreme ownership for myself.
I'm going to read at night and then I'm
going to become a good leader and I'm
going to do better at work. Don't
do that. That's the wrong move.
What you want to do. You want to actually
distribute it to your team. Yeah.
And that way they all get on board and
now the whole team starts kicking ass.
That's what you want to do.
Up and down the chain of command.
Then if you need more than that,
you can hire our leadership and management
consultant company. Echelon fun. We are
the premier leadership consulting company
in the entire world,
so we're the ones that teach the methods
and the techniques and the tactics and
procedures from extreme
ownership proven in combat.
So you can email contact us info national
on front.com we just had the muster
number two in New York City,
uh,
awesome event. If you
missed it, come to Texas,
July,
1314 Omni Barton creek resort and spa.
And again, forget about the spa. You're
not going to spa and I'll come to the spa.
Not happening, but well, what
will be happening as leadership.
We'll talk about combat leadership and
how to apply that to your business and to
your life. And if you can't make
Texas, it's okay. We got backup,
we got contingency operations.
If you can't come to Texas,
September 14th and 15th we will be back
in San Diego on my home turf where there
is no winter. We got big yards
and Barbara can you spoiled?
You're entitled abuse spoiled.
At this point in your life.
It's, it's, I'll take you,
I'll give you a pass on that until the
musters we can be found actually on the
interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram it into Facebook.
I'm going to find it.
There.
Hardly is at Harley F Flanagan
and Flanagan is spelledF , l. A n. A.
G a n hardly F Flanagan.
Echo is at echocharles
in I am at Jocko Willink.
Okay.
Echo, you got anything
else? Nope, that's it man.
Gentlemen, who was real
pleasure. Absolutely. Yeah.
Any other closing
comments you want to make?
Okay.
I definitely wouldn't advise
smoking PCP taking a list.
No, seriously. I'm not.
Thanks for having me on, man.
It's a real pleasure. You know, I, you're,
you've become a big inspiration.
I love reading your quotes and your
books and I'm listening to the podcast.
It's sometimes it's exactly the
kick in the ass that I need and uh,
I appreciate that. And, uh, and again,
I'm very honored and proud to have been
a part of the soundtrack to your life.
Indeed. Yes, indeed. Uh,
I'd also like to give a shout out to my
better half who without her I definitely
wouldn't be doing so well.
My book would not be as good.
It would probably suck and my
life would definitely suck.
So Laura Leaf land again.
I love you and uh,
if my sons are listening to this podcast,
I love you boys and uh,
okay.
Keep up the good work and keep your
training going and keep checking out.
Jocko is podcasts you
might learn a thing or two.
Awesome. Well, uh,
Harley obviously thanks for coming
on the show and such a pleasure man.
Thanks for the years of music that you
gave to me and millions of other kids
that needed to hear it.
And thanks for making it through what
you've made it through and coming out on
the other side with a,
with a positive outlook and a positive
impact in a positive message that
it's
never too late.
It is never too dark and that
we can always turn things around
as long as you're alive.
There is hope.
Yes indeed.
Thanks to everyone else that's listening
and supporting and spreading the word.
And as always to the folks
in the military out there,
we salute you and thank you all
for holding the demons at the gate.
Okay.
And to the police and law
enforcement and firefighters and he,
mts and first responders.
Thanks for fighting
the demons here at home
and
to anyone else that's out
there that's listening, that's
okay.
Started to go down,
down in that hole,
down into that more
trapped in the chains of
depression or addiction or rage.
When you're down in that hole,
look up,
look up and recognize
that there is a way out.
There is a path for you to take.
Yeah.
And it's not an easy path.
It'll be a fight.
It will be a fight that demands focus
and work and tenacity and of course
discipline.
But it is that path,
that hard path,
that hard path of discipline
that will lead you to freedom.
So stay on that path.
And until next time,
this is Harley Flanagan and deco and Jocko
help.